Okay.
Hello?
We're live.
Oh,
we are live right now.
Yes,
we live.
Brian,
what are you doing over there?
Nothing.
Fixing some shit on my phone.
I woke up today and my safari app is
just missing from my phone and that's
not an app you can download from the APP
store.
So it's like how the fuck do you,
like you say you woke up and this
happened,
but do you really remember last night?
Yeah,
except I didn't eat last night.
I doubt.
I doubt you remember the last few hours
I did.
I have this problem lately.
How fucked up was he?
No,
he was getting liquored up and I saw
him.
You were getting looked at like for like
eight weren't,
you know,
I didn't start drinking until after I
got off stage and stuff.
But I did a thing where I woke up and I
tell people like,
oh yeah,
I'll do your podcast,
but I don't write it down.
And then like I was in bed and somebody
said,
hey,
I'll see you at the laugh factory in 40
minutes and I'm like,
what?
You got to remind me?
Or something.
That's,
by the way,
that exact same thing happened when you
did my podcast.
Just give response,
Brian,
let's not,
let's not write it off to one night.
Why don't you use the calendar feature
in your phone?
I do,
but I only do it for his shows.
It seems like by like little things like
podcasts,
stuff.
I never really always,
that's not a little thing.
Well,
I always think that people would like
remind me,
you know,
like not 40 minutes before,
be like,
Hey,
I'll see you tomorrow.
And I'm like,
okay.
Oh yeah,
that.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
But then I,
after that I had another one that I
completely forgot about,
so then I had to go to the comedy show
last night.
So I think bread is making an excellent
point.
They shouldn't write it off to other
people.
No,
it's totally me.
You should keep a calendar though.
It's totally me,
Brian.
I don't think of podcasts is a little
thing at all.
Like if I'm going to do some of these
podcasts,
that's a big deal.
No,
no.
But when you're like at a comedy clubs
stoned and someone goes,
hey,
you should do my podcast next Monday.
Yeah,
I've done that.
That's a different animal.
You got to ask people.
I'm like an email or a text,
like asking someone in person unless
you,
unless you're both sober,
you know.
And another problem I have is when
people give me their numbers,
I don't save it in my phone.
And they said when they text me like a
month later,
I'm like,
oh fuck.
Who is this guy that's texting?
I do this to you.
I don't know if you know I do this to
everyone.
Everyone.
I always write burt at the end of my
texts because I'm like,
I don't know if they got a new phone
because I just want them to know,
hey,
this is Bert.
I always wondered why he did that cause
I don't cause I don't eat it
totally yours Bert.
Yeah,
it's a little odd,
but there's,
you know,
see sometimes people do weird things
like,
do you ever get an email from someone
and they have like a tag line and their
email sent for my silly iphone,
excuse the voice darling things.
Jesus Christ.
We really needed to do this
Hashtag.
Like if you ever do your own Hashtag
[inaudible]
well the guy uh,
um,
Dominic Monaghan,
really nice car.
Yeah.
Like on a lot,
but
that'd be instagram posts he makes,
he puts Hashtag be curious.
Oh Hey,
how about if I don't want to be curious,
check.
Cool.
Can I just fucking vege out over here?
That's done.
But the curiosity is what got me to your
instagram.
Yeah.
So he dumps sometimes like to put my
feet up and have a beer and not thinking
about shit.
I'm not always interested in being
curious.
Be Sad.
Hashtag be sad.
He saw he's got some
travel channel show about like he's
traveling all over the world and seeing
all these weird animals and he's like,
he's got a genuine passion for it.
The wild things with dom,
it's on travel to you.
He loves insects.
Matt,
we had some deep conversations about
ants.
Really?
Dude,
seriously in the ants.
Well I am too in a way.
You know,
not like him.
I don't know as much,
but I've watched quite a few
documentaries on it and it's like when I
watch them and like this is amazing.
They,
they,
they just know how to go places.
They're all like in the same row and
we're trying to figure out how they do
it.
It's by pheromones and shit and then you
see these super complex civilizations
that they build underground,
especially those leaf cutter ants.
Have you seen that shit dude?
Leafcutter ants are so sophisticated
that they've,
they've engineered some sort of like
ventilation system so they could bring
leaves down into their crazy house and
they'll ferment,
they'll,
these leaves will ferment in these like
bowls that they've dug into the ground
and there's a pipe above it that's like
an air pipe that they've tunneled up
through the surface just to allow the
gases to escape.
No explanation whatsoever.
How they all know how to do this.
No explanation how they ever figured it
out.
I mean it's super complicated.
They've been programmed that way.
Yeah.
I mean,
something's going on,
man.
Have you ever seen when they pour cement
into these things?
Oh yes.
I have seen this too.
We pull,
can you pull that up?
I want to think they pulled posy melanin
and then they pull it out and it looks
like an art project.
Yeah.
Well it's this giant labyrinth of
tunnels and there it is.
Yeah.
Go look at that.
God Damn.
Wow.
That's so cool.
I mean,
how were they all communicating together
to figure this out?
This is,
that's not one is it?
What does that,
that's an a Wa wasp masterson.
What is that?
Whoa.
An ant queen.
Um,
go to that.
The leaf cutter ant,
there was a video of it,
I think you find it and they showed how
they did it,
how they poured the water in or the
concrete in rather,
which is kind of rude,
I think about it.
How many ants that's an ant.
Genocide were just saying,
oh,
amazing.
Hashtag be curious.
Yeah.
Sadly dialed in because we're talking
about and see what they do in here.
Yeah.
They're pouring it into this whole,
I mean this is like,
that looks like either pouring molten
metal.
Is that metal?
Aluminum?
I'm pretty sure how rude I know.
Got All these.
All these answers are like,
what the fuck dude?
What the fuck my family's in there,
my fucking kids,
dude.
What the fuck?
Look at the ants.
Just like freaking out around the edge.
So they pour this molten aluminum in and
fill the whole thing and then this
serial killer asshole.
What a spatula.
He's got a little spatula.
It's designed to sound like guess is
that a gal or a dude?
It's hard to tell.
Might be a man Bun,
but whoever it is is gentlemen or a
woman is going to go in there and dig
the whole thing out now and it's a piece
of art.
Wow.
That's actually a pretty dope piece of
art.
Finished casting 21 inches wide hunting
big 14.5
inches high and it weighs three pounds.
Wow.
And Aster Harvester ant casting brought
to you by,
so it's an oh aunt caster.com.
So it's a company that murders ants for
you.
That's real big.
Gives a fuck if you kill ants.
It is one of the weirdest things,
dude.
You could,
you could kill an ant on your pants and
brush it to the ground in any
respectable office and nobody freaks
out.
Yeah,
yeah.
No one says,
where'd you kill bees these days?
People get pissed.
They get pissed and they should.
Yeah,
we don't have any many bees,
you know,
running out and bees and we want to keep
our cell phones and we want to keep
pesticide.
So we'd had a piece in pests and cell
phones and petrified connect.
Well,
I'm not a bee expert,
I should just say that off the bat,
but what I've read is that they're
pretty sure that bees are affected by
cell phone signals and some sort of a
negative way.
And it interferes with their ability to
communicate with each other up.
Or there's another possible thought is
that they might be hearing this,
the sound of the cell phone signal all
the time,
and it's just driving them nuts.
It's just interfering or intruding in
their life.
The cell phone service,
the frequencies are making b's autistics
so they can't talk to each other.
That's why autism or up is up.
Awesome.
Big Autism epidemic interviews.
When we were on fear factor,
we did,
we had this instant we were up in um,
or they're going to say you did it with
autistic.
He's autistic fuckers lied to them,
you know,
um,
they had this um,
this stumbling recovering people in bees
and so we're on this ranch and uh,
they had these people and they would
stand there like leaning up against a
pole and this guy would come over with
these and just coat them with bs,
like scoop it on them.
They had a stand with a bs on him for a
certain amount of time.
I don't remember how,
maybe they had to like unlock locks or
something stupid.
But while this was going on,
this local colony of bees showed up.
So it was like a b gang meeting.
Like they had to have a meeting and we
had leave.
Like the guy who's the bee guy goes,
okay,
here's the situation.
There is a local colony that just came
to investigate why my colonies here,
we have to let them work this out.
And I was like,
what?
Like what are you talking about?
And so we,
we,
we had to all leave the set.
So we all left the set and we went over
like by these trailers that they had set
up and we kind of watched these bees
just fly around each other should oh
yeah.
And they had to figure each other out.
They had to figure out like,
what are you guys doing here?
Oh we're filming a show.
Oh what did we watch it?
And then they had like,
they had a talk,
like they had to have a meeting and we
don't,
we're not moving in,
we don't live here.
We live like down there in that thing.
I mean obviously they didn't use English
but somehow or another they communicated
whatever they needed to and like 20
minutes later.
So we were allowed to go back to work.
Or they're dead bees on the ground when
you got over there?
No,
I don't think so.
It's hard to find them.
I mean if there were just finding a dead
being on the ground,
but I mean like if there were,
there'll be more than one you'd imagine
like maybe like 30 dead bees on the
ground,
like 300,
300 bees,
the movie 300 fucking xerxes victims
everywhere.
Have you ever driven through a,
uh,
a big flock of fluff,
fluff or bs?
Oh,
oh,
swarm of bees.
No,
I live in through like spock,
spock snack,
all of the windshield,
uh,
over by NBC in Burbank.
You know,
that like right off Alameda,
that back road I was driving through one
time I had my windows down and all of a
sudden thought maybe a thousand bees
just flying around and all in the car.
And I was like,
mother,
wow.
I just kept driving and I just sped up.
And I was like,
and they came in and out of the car
pretty quickly,
but it was,
I drove right through them.
And that same thing happened in front of
our house.
In front of our house.
There's a dead,
uh,
like elm tree or something or a walnut
tree.
It was a walnut grove.
And it's all hollowed out.
And there were like a thousand bees
living inside that and my daughter's
terrified of bees and our neighbor just
went in and put like a song,
like a towel in the top and just lock
them in and had them die.
What I mean,
fucker,
he's a dick.
Jesus Christ.
Did you ever see the,
um,
there was a guy,
I think it was long island that found
this mega
colony in his attic.
He went up in his attic and it was
either aunts or I use either a bees or
wasps.
I don't know what,
I don't remember which one it was,
but what I remember is this fucking guy
was up in his attic and it was like,
Holy Shit,
we're talking about something as big as
this table is an enormous,
enormous bee colony in his attic.
They just had found a way through that
says,
fuck,
it's warm in here.
Let's,
let's keep,
and he just never went up there.
And so they just kept building this
goddamn thing.
So it was this huge shelter that's
they've got,
uh,
Africa is a video of a Jamie,
if you could find it.
They are africanized bees in business.
Oddly enough,
like all over that.
I saw that online one time.
Literally the,
those are the killer bees.
Those are the bad ones.
And they got dudes that,
I think it was a TV show now that I said
that sounds like I fucking read
something.
But it was a reality show about a guy
who would just get rid of Ackford
africanized bees.
Those are the scary ones.
Yeah.
Remember when you were a kid and
everyone was scared of African killer
bees,
quicksand.
The killer bees.
Then we've talked about this,
I think before her quicksand go,
they turn into porn,
quicksand,
bs.
I mean,
I thought there was a bunch of shit that
was going to get me the Russians,
Russia,
Russia.
Tell me about it.
And when you were a kid,
fuck yeah,
I thought the bomb was going to happen.
He's fucking kids today.
They don't know these fucking kids
today.
Let me tell you something.
Last night.
Joey Diaz is on stage at the hall.
I'm not going to do is bid at all.
I don't even know if it's a bit or it's
him talking because quite honestly I
watched him smoke maybe 10 cup fulls of
Hash on vine before he came there.
But he was doing this bit,
I'm in the back just kind of watching
him and he's doing this bit about
watching two dogs.
Fuck,
but you don't don't,
you're not going to do it.
But what was happening was there were
these two,
I'm going to say gay hipsters,
they a man bonds and they were just
looking at each other.
They're like shaking their head going,
that's not true.
And I was like,
Oh man,
like our kids are so far removed from
like the stray dogs fucking in your
front yard that these guys think that
dogs,
you just adopt them.
And they like the throw almost
genetically made in laboratories that
they don't just fuck on the streets like
that.
It was so interesting to watch these two
kids just go like,
well that's sort of true premise of
Joey's bit that,
you know,
you don't see that anymore.
Yeah,
no,
but it was watching these kids just look
each other and just shake their head.
And I was like,
who the,
like I remember watching,
I remember seeing that when I was a kid.
Yeah.
He always pit.
It's so funny,
Dude.
He was hilarious last night.
Tuesday night at the store too.
He was on fire Tuesday night at the
store.
He was on fire and he just gets off
stage.
He's like,
bye.
I'll go.
I thought we were going to hang out.
No,
fuck that cock sucker.
I got to go.
I'll see how I'll come over your house
for girl scout cookies.
I got to go.
Yeah.
It's pretty funny and crazy.
What happened at Lee?
Uh,
being like,
out of everyone that we know,
all the Comedians,
Lee,
his,
a assistant on his podcast is banned
from that.
That,
that,
that hotel,
the uh,
uh,
silver point.
What is it?
South Pointe,
south point banned for life.
What hotel he was given out.
Um,
allegedly he gave his star to somebody.
Should we tell the story?
I don't know if we don't know if
allegedly gave a star.
Probably shouldn't tell his story.
He was starting out.
This was a story there.
He's on it.
It's on his Paris or in his podcast.
You?
No,
no.
Let me tell you something.
Joey.
Joey came about the guy who makes our
tee shirts.
He gave us his phone number online and
he called me.
He goes,
do you ever do business with that cock
sucker again?
I'll fucking kill you.
I was like,
Joey,
I already have a shirt order.
And he's like,
cancel it.
Cancel it to mirror him.
So I think I had to go through a new
people to get money and my shirts.
Fuck yeah.
Cause you think you want to fuck with
Joey?
What was it about?
Nothing.
Fucking nothing.
Sometimes like I don't,
I mean I don't know what it was like,
but joy wouldn't tell me.
He was like,
ah,
fuck him.
It had to be something.
It's,
it's,
Oh,
I would assume.
Oh yeah.
Joey has been on a tear lately.
Hasn't been,
well,
Joey doesn't give a fuck if he,
if he thinks you're a piece of shit,
he wants to know what are these?
This is the new shirts from the time I
fought the bear.
Can you see it?
No.
It says marshmallow.
What is it?
I don't get to bear the bear face and it
says marshmallow in it.
Oh,
now I get it.
Yeah.
So I thought a bear,
I've told you the story before,
but I got,
I got one for all you guys and there's
an extra one leftover.
I shouldn't put them right in front of
us.
That's going to be distracting.
So this guy's a new guy that made your
shirts.
Yeah.
You couldn't do it with the guy that
Joe,
he hates tillys.
Hmm.
Joey's loyal man.
But it was the one thing about that guy.
He's definitely that.
Yeah.
Joey's a is very passionate.
I don't know what happened,
but he's great if you're great to him.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's great.
If you great to him.
But if you fuck them over,
if you achler cunt,
he comes down and comes down hard.
He'll call you on it first.
And have you ever,
has he ever called you on something you
did like just been joined?
I had been remarkably friendly forever.
Oh,
remarkably.
Like even if we got upset at each other
for anything,
it was very,
very minor.
Yeah.
And it's usually,
cause he had any food yet or if he's
gotten upset at anything,
like the mass he ever got was when I
couldn't figure out where we should eat
in Austin landed,
we landed and we're driving and like,
where do you,
where do you guys want to go?
Fucking five,
five,
somewhere.
You got that fucking phone in your
pocket,
take the fucking phone out of your
pocket.
She just quite jump up and call
somebody.
And he was in,
he was like the worst.
Uh,
he was in the worst health of all the
time that I've known him.
He was real big then,
like real heavy.
And He,
um,
you know,
it's just when you get like that,
I don't know what it is that,
that blood sugar spike thing where you
just fucking need to eat right now.
You're,
you're freaking out.
He gets there,
he gets to that spot.
Oh he got it.
He got on me one time cause uh,
he called me and I didn't answer and
they called again.
I didn't answer and he called a third
time and I still didn't answer.
And then they started calling
aggressively when I was like,
oh.
And I was like,
oh,
something's wrong.
So I pick up the phone and he goes,
no,
we're fucking friends.
If I call,
that means I need to talk to you.
You pick up your fucking phone ward off
fucking friends.
Do you understand that I'm having like
flashbacks?
And he talked like that and I go and I
just,
I was like,
but I just didn't know not I just,
I call you see my name,
you fucking call me back.
How crazy he is with the fucking
voicemails.
He can't leave a voicemail.
You can't leave it.
You call me,
you call me.
I go,
what will come on joey go.
Why do you want everybody else to follow
these rules?
These rules don't make sense if it's so
easy to just text you a message.
Say Hey brother showed tonight is at 10
why isn't that
okay,
why isn't that okay because I'm
insecure.
I want to talk to you,
want to look you in the eyes like a man.
He going to fucking tell me something
and the next best thing is talking to
you on the phone.
It's hard to argue with that.
No more voicemail APP is an APP that
kills voicemail so cars have to text you
and I'm pretty sure you could just turn
off voicemail.
Just let it fill up fucking APP.
I just slipped that bitch fill up.
Let me tell you something.
I never checked those things.
Joey's been to every Easter at my house,
every Christmas Eve,
every Christmas dinner for the past ever
since I've known him because that
because that and that it's,
it's interesting cause it's helped
blossom a part of my personality because
I'm really fucking,
I got intimacy issues like I don't like,
I like to be friends to people,
but my phone calls,
we're usually pretty short.
I don't want to bother people.
I'm just afraid people bother people
being considerate.
But Joey is one of those guys,
like the first,
I think we have first Easter.
We invited to him,
him to him and my dad got along really
fine.
He gave my dad my dad,
marijuana and fucking I was there.
Yeah,
I edible medical marijuana and Dosim or
did he tell him when he was doing,
Kevin offered him,
offered him some popcorn.
You know Joey is just pop Mr k take some
of this and it's fucking edible
marijuana.
My Dad eats something and my dad is
like,
and I go,
dad,
that's edible marijuana.
And he goes,
no buddy,
it's popcorn.
I go,
no,
that.
How old's your dad?
67 right now probably.
And what was he doing back when pop was
kicking?
He tried it a couple times,
but he wasn't like he was a runner so he
didn't do it.
And then Joey just starts laughing.
Mr Is going deep motherfuckers this and
so I go,
I go over,
I go,
Joe,
did you just give him marijuana?
He goes,
he took it.
No,
I didn't give it to him.
He took it.
So I can't even fucking person expects
no 69 year old guy to know what the fuck
pop popcorn is the most 20 year old kids
all across the country.
Don't know it popped popcorn is joe.
There's a picture I have of my dad.
I'm not even lying with his hand into
his mouth like this and joey with that
big joey like fucking laughing and,
and I,
and then immediately I was like,
my dad's like,
well what do I do?
And I was like,
and Joey's like,
you're going with him dog.
Just hey me some on my wife's losing her
fucking mind.
Now everyone's on edibles on Easter
morning in fucking all the kids are
Easter egg hunting.
I go into the man cave,
I locked the doors.
We're podcasting cocksuckers turns on my
black ass and equipment.
We do probably my most epic podcast
ever.
Wow.
Of just joey.
Just,
oh,
but he's like,
but I'll tell you what.
Your Dad had fun though,
right?
My Dad had a blast.
You want to know the really best part
that night.
We all leave day.
Everyone leaves that night.
Me and my dad sat in my seven,
went to my sister's house set outside,
had a cigar and my dad is always had a
problem,
my lifestyle and he just,
and we're both higher than Giraffe,
pussy and he's like,
he's like,
buddy,
I want to tell you why I bother you
about your lifestyle.
My father reminded me so much of you,
my father died when he was 42 from blood
pressure issues and I,
and I've,
and I've never been one to hound you,
but you need to go to it.
I want you to go to a cardiologist,
get a ct scan,
I want you to get the full comprehensive
thing right now.
And I was like,
and he goes,
I said,
if I did that,
would that make you feel comfortable?
And he goes,
that would change my life.
And I was like,
why do we have to be high to have this
conversation?
And I,
so the fucking next month I went in,
I got a full fucking comprehensive
overview.
Totally fine.
High blood pressure,
but totally fine.
My Dad is like my,
my,
I'm bound me fucking around when I say
this.
My Dad loves Joey Diaz because of that
moment,
because he got,
he got my dad,
a very uptight guy to a place where you
could kind of connect with me and talk
to me for the first time like that and
go,
you know you're drinking.
I don't know if you do drugs on the
road.
I don't know what you do.
And My,
and we just had a great conversation and
every fucking family event we ever had
at my dad's at my dad's like,
did you call Joey?
Just fucking loves.
He loves his daughter.
Yeah.
Like my dad loves joey.
Really?
Literally.
Everybody knows joey loves joey.
Oh yeah.
Oh my kids fucking love him.
Yeah.
Oh,
he calls [inaudible] El Diablo.
When he goes off,
man,
you just gotta back away like that John
Copper rule thing.
Hey,
a cap rule was asking me to get involve
and I'm like,
you're on your own dude.
You're on your own.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
I was outside of that.
I wasn't at the store.
All this shit was going down.
I don't know what cap rule.
Oh,
did that piss joe off so much,
but joey's insistent,
you know?
Yeah.
I didn't want to hear it.
I'm like,
why?
Just going to work this out?
Just watching it on twitter was insane.
Every three seconds.
If it was you and him,
I would have to get involved,
but I have to go,
okay,
what happened?
What the fuck is going on?
But with cat,
I don't know capra role that well.
I just know him like,
Hey,
what's up man?
How much you're on your own.
Sorry Dude.
I don't know what to tell you of one
guy's my brother and the other guy
barely.
I barely know you.
I mean,
I know you like hi,
but like we never hang out.
I don't,
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what you did,
but joey,
when he gets this thought in his head
that you're the enemy,
you know he fucking,
he doesn't let it go.
Like if I,
if,
if he saw Tommy today,
like Tommy from the old comedy store,
he would spit in his face.
Like he would get fucking crazy.
Yeah,
he,
he's just,
he's the real deal.
Like would you sleep what you get?
There's no act is no,
and that's when Joey really became joey
on stage because Joey was always the
funniest guy in the parking lot.
And then he would go on stage and I
don't know what it is man.
He just couldn't figure out,
you know,
those tense moments.
Like I was watching someone last night,
there was just starting doing comedy and
choose doing a set and I could tell like
she's got potential but she just can't
get comfortable up there.
She can't be herself.
You know,
there's like this something,
these thoughts,
this,
this like compression that's holding you
back.
Joe.
We had that and one day he didn't have
it anymore.
I mean it was crazy and we had been
friends for like a couple of years and
he just wasn't doing well.
Like,
cause he wasn't doing well on stage and
then all the sudden he was murdering.
Like,
I've never seen anything like it before.
It was like a switch flipped and as a
different person out there and he was
the same guy from the parking lot.
Does it matter who the fuck's in the
crowd?
It didn't matter.
He would say shit you like,
how the fuck did you just say a racist
shit?
And you know,
it was just the most ridiculous shit and
really fucking funny.
All of a sudden I outta nowhere
he was,
he was inspirational last night.
Like I watched him in the back.
I know Joey,
I know Joe really well.
Like I mean like,
but men,
I'll watch him and I was like,
that's the same voice.
You're doing the same voice.
You call me on the phone with his
onstage and you're not.
And I didn't feel like anything was a
bit,
I felt like it was really morphed into
him.
I was just uncle joey talking to your
cock sock as well.
He's real dedicated right now.
You know,
he's,
he's out there huffing it every night.
He's putting in a lot of sets or dude,
he calls me up.
He goes,
Dude Ha.
And every fucking Wednesday night.
It's fucking five minutes from your
house.
Cock sucker.
I'll pick you up.
I go there.
I went there last night.
It's amazing.
I did it.
I had a great time,
man.
Ron and the owners are so fucking cool.
Jack,
really,
really juniors.
His son runs the Wednesday night workout
and it's just,
it was,
I mean,
I,
I'm telling you,
man,
I you,
I've told you this,
we've had this conversation a lot.
I'll say it out loud.
Um,
I'm,
when you get back in to stand up.
Oh,
it's like,
it's like working out when you do you
ever,
I don't know.
I'm not saying this only to joe now.
Right now you ever workout so much where
when you sit down and you can feel your
abs tighten up,
you're like,
I feel good man.
I'm in good shape right now.
Like that's what,
when you're doing standup like that,
like all the fucking time you're back.
It's nice and tight.
Yeah.
And I'm in fucking hard core fucking
standup mode.
Nice.
I love it,
man.
I love it so much.
But we were talking about this,
that you do that show so much that maybe
it's reached the point where the show
was kind of getting in the way.
It's,
I didn't realize it.
And you had said that to me at one
point.
You'd said a couple of things to me that
we're a little heavy that I couldn't,
that I couldn't wrap my head around.
And I think it was man,
no,
I think it was,
cause I wasn't doing standup.
I didn't understand what I was trying to
do.
But you,
you get into production mode.
Well what did I say that was heavy?
One thing you said,
the two things you said is he stopped
doing that show.
You need to get back on stage.
You're too good of a comic to fucking
not be doing standup like all the time.
And then the other thing you said was
you've gotta be looking at this show
you're doing and you need to be writing
about this on stage.
The problem is I couldn't write about
what I was doing.
I didn't know how to write about these
activities because I wasn't a standup
mode.
I was in production mode.
Right?
Like what times are called time?
What Time's the flight leaves?
How much time do we need?
Crazy.
You live such an adventurous life and
yet you don't talk about it on stage and
you're all over the world.
Oh Dude.
I,
I just now,
just this past week and I'm gearing up
to do my hour.
I got to say this before I forget.
Uh,
I am taping my hour special for
showtime,
April 1st at the Irvine Improv.
If you'd like to get tickets,
you can go to my twitter feed.
You can get a link right there or go to
the Irvine Improv two shows Friday
night.
Um,
uh,
seven 30 and eight.
They have Lao half hour set,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
I'm,
I'm fucked up.
No,
seven 30 and 10 or whatever.
Seven 30 to 10.
That's a quick 10 minute special.
You're releasing your special on vine.
Yeah.
So go to go to the urban and probably
get tickets because I'd like to sell it
out.
I'd like to have a packed room and it's
like a 500 seat or why wouldn't you like
to have an empty?
I'd like to,
I'd like to sell it out.
I would like to show to be successful,
so please laugh.
Oh fuck it.
Yeah.
They Irvine in probes this shit to the
new places.
Really excellent.
Callen filmed his thing there.
Really?
Yeah,
it's great.
I opened for him.
It's a suite.
It's a real nice setup man.
It's,
it looks beautiful.
Yeah,
I've done it a couple of times on
Tuesday too.
They were fun Tuesday night there.
I think I did a weekend there.
Wants to,
it's great.
Yeah.
The new Irvine Improv's fucking smoking.
It's perfect.
And I,
I kept looking at like,
I mean all these shows,
I mean so easy to see specials on
Netflix,
but like everything looked for me,
looked a little cookie cutter where it
was like everything was done,
like a certain type of thing.
I was like,
I don't do theaters.
It makes sense that you are,
bill would do a theater show.
I don't know.
What do,
what do I ever do if I'm not doing
theaters anymore for a specials?
I,
yeah,
she did theater theaters.
If I'm in a place like vegas or if I
want to go to a town for one night,
we'll do it.
Theater.
But yeah.
Arenas,
nationals,
hockey arena with the ice.
No,
I can't skate at all man.
It would be a lot of shitty movement.
Who did you say that to us?
Action.
Bronson Action Bronson.
That is the funniest goddamn interview
when you're docking and you just,
he's like talking like he's being,
he's totally action Bronson and that and
you just go,
I can't skate.
I laughed hysterically.
Fuck is serious.
Oh,
you're not skiing on Pluto.
We were so high during that interview.
It was so ridiculous.
And he kept going.
He smoked it like a cigarette.
Yeah,
he kept going.
He does that all day.
He's just constantly going here like a
fucking,
like you ever see those when those Cuban
cigar rollers,
the role,
like there's fucking stack of the day.
Yeah.
That's what he had with him.
Like just stack of blunt.
He's,
I'm telling you that I've forgotten 19
million things to talk to you about,
but like that Viceland I'm fucking
fascinated.
Viceland is great.
The show's great.
His,
uh,
his show is excellent too.
Fuck,
that's delicious.
I watch that.
I found that at the beach one weekend
and I watched all of them back.
Actually,
food shows are great,
but the way he does it,
it's real.
It's not,
it's not like I'm here at the dot,
dot,
dot.
And we're ready to,
you know,
I did that for when we did reshot birth
to conquer.
And I'm not,
I'm not saying I stole from action,
John Bronson,
but like,
after watching enough content,
I was like,
I don't need the intros.
I don't need any of this shit.
Just give me the action.
Right.
So when we did birth,
it's not gonna air for a little maybe
ever,
I don't know until June.
But,
uh,
it,
there's no intros.
None of that's just real.
And that's the way it,
that's the way content should be done.
Yeah.
Maybe a short introduction,
like staring at the camera like you
would if your friends were there.
Yeah,
yeah.
Instead of this super polished
professional thing,
I,
the problem with your show is it's a
great show.
You love doing it,
but you take months away from stand up.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's just,
that's just too much for guys.
Funny as you,
it doesn't make any sense.
I don't think I saw that until I started
getting back on stage and going like,
oh fuck man.
You know what?
What happens when you don't do it all
the time is you don't work on your
jokes.
You don't take that bit,
you know,
like you can't,
yeah.
You just do it one time.
You're like,
it worked.
I'm good.
You Go,
the only way you could really do standup
is it do it all the time.
And to do it in front of audiences all
the time.
Like that's how they,
the bits have to come together.
They can't do it on your own need.
People.
You gotta be in that zone.
I'm bill.
Bill and I,
Bill was talking to me about it.
Um,
and I had said something like,
man,
I gotta go,
I gotta go knock the rust off.
And I was like,
well,
what was I telling you on stage?
He's like,
last Sunday I went,
hold on.
I've spent like months off stage and he
was like,
he was like,
how can you do that once is rough.
If I take a week off,
I don't like it.
If I take two weeks off,
it feels like I can take a week off.
If I'm going on vacation,
I'll say,
okay,
I'm going on vacation.
I'm not thinking about shit when I go on
vacation.
I am making a concerted effort to just
pay attention to entertainment.
Like,
like I watch movies or I'll read a book
or,
uh,
maybe I'll check twitter real quick to
see if anything wacky is going on the
world.
And that's it.
Like very little,
very little.
I don't want to take anything.
I don't want to talk about business.
I don't give a fuck.
I just just want to hang out and chill
so I can do that.
But when I'm like,
if I take a week off and I just haven't
done stand up and then I get back on
stage again,
I feel like I got to get the,
the engine cranking again.
Yeah.
So the longest I've ever taken off from
surgery,
I think,
uh,
when I,
when I twisted my knee,
I took maybe a month off or something
like that.
Yeah.
After acl surgery may be a little more
than a month.
It gets weird.
It does.
And you lose money.
For me,
I ride a lot.
I read a lot and like onstage,
so I lose material.
So all those like tags and I lose like
big chunks where I go one day,
I'm all of a sudden I'm like,
oh wait,
whatever happened.
That fucking joke.
Is it travel channel cool with you not
doing that show or do they want to keep
doing it?
Do you,
uh,
I don't know.
You're doing birth to conquer for them
as well,
right?
Uh,
right now we're doing two shows,
but I'm not doing anything.
I was kind of understood I was going to
take a little bit of a sabbatical right
to focus on stand up and my agents were
reached out and they're like,
you know,
technically I don't have to work all the
time.
I was just doing it because I wanted
money when they were and they were like,
we're cool with just the base of the
deal and then give him the time to do
stand up.
And then I got back and stand up and I
was like,
I started going like,
okay,
I can't,
I can't do the show the way I normally
do.
I can't just go and go,
all right,
let's two weeks go to fucking
Micronesia.
Right.
Like I was like,
I need to be,
I need to be on stage at every,
every week.
I need to and but for me,
you know,
the store at the store and like some of
the smaller clubs,
I like doing an hour.
I like working the hour.
So I liked being in,
in a,
on the road fucking Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Why don't you do a show if you're going
to do a show for them,
a show that involved stand up.
I mean it's the damn travel channel.
How about you do a show where you go and
you do stand up on the road and then you
go out to places?
Sort of like a Dave attell used to have
like insomniac.
Yeah,
that kind of a thing.
Just visiting places and then come up
with shit to do and those places that
you visit,
we may,
we can do both.
We made,
I don't need,
the network's changed direction so we
don't know exactly what's going to
happen with any,
anyone really except was really the,
I candidly,
I think everyone knows us,
but the network kind of did like a
cleaning house and moved everyone to
Knoxville and left Chevy Chase Maryland
and there's a new president and the new
Svp,
Knoxville,
Tennessee.
That's where scripts is headquartered.
Scripts.
Scripts owns travel channel.
They own diy.
Hobb used to know this shit.
You're saying that like,
no,
everyone knows this check.
Come on.
Joe Didn't know the words out.
Scram word is this.
They'd been my boss for six years.
I can't imagine anyone doesn't.
You're such an industry guy,
but Knoxville,
Tennessee.
What the fuck is that place like?
I was pretty cool.
Yeah.
They,
the old colony club is right around the
corner from where scripts headquarters
is.
What comic comes down.
Oh,
it's broken down now.
It's like just some beat up and just got
the,
like the theoretically like the chuckle
hut sig signature on the thing.
Is it not exist in any more that
existed.
But man,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I had an extra chunk of change,
I'd fucking open it.
Cause I love those little box comedy
clubs that,
you know,
like the punchline Atlanta.
Yeah.
Ponch on Atlanta was such a great
fucking club.
Wait,
that's not open anymore.
No,
it's closed.
When under gene meet member Jamie from
the punchline.
He's going to get me that piece of,
uh,
there was a piece of wallboard that
says,
quit trying to be Hicks.
Yeah.
Somebody wrote it.
And graffiti.
I love that fucking thing.
I have a photo of that.
Yeah.
I always thought that was hilarious.
That was a great fucking club.
What took its place down there?
Well,
they had parking issues.
If you remember,
they always had parking issues and uh,
I don't know if they lost their lease.
I don't know what happened,
but I guess the reopening,
they're gonna open up a new one
somewhere else.
If I'm not mistaken,
they might've already reopened.
Say,
gave me an offer for the weekend before
my special and that's good.
But I think right now they're like in
limbo.
Okay.
They have the laughing skull there too.
Great.
Is there this weekend?
Really?
Yeah.
Fitzsimmons is going there this weekend.
I don't think he's ever been there
before.
We were talking to him about how awesome
it is.
And then there's,
um,
the Improv now,
right?
Yeah.
Probably supposed to be pretty good
there too.
I've done that one too.
That's good.
As seats.
A lot more.
How many people?
A lot.
It's probably,
I'm probably three 20.
Okay.
He's out there.
Do a lot of big club's now.
Like,
um,
they're doing like the 500 cedars,
like those kind of like the new Irvine
Improv is 500 plus seats.
Columbus.
Funnybone.
Yeah.
Funny Bone.
We're talking about that last night I'm
doing a call and said to work show March
17th there I told you about these.
I go in and do radio.
I drink and then do like an 11:00
AM show.
Oh really?
They've sold out everywhere.
I've never had them not sell out.
So they're like,
they're funny shit,
but it's a,
it's like 11 to him showing everyone
just calls in sick to work and get
fucking blitzed.
So it's Saint Patty's Day.
It's true.
He's like it fucking insane.
They're insane.
What does your dad worried about with
your lifestyle?
That's weird,
dude.
In the why you would be worried about
your drink dialed in.
I got,
but I can lighten up my party and I
don't party as hard as people think
you're,
he's my canary now.
Like that's a perfect canary,
right?
I'm not,
I'm not anyone.
He doesn't smoke cigarettes.
Yeah,
it's true.
How much do you weigh right now?
Uh,
two oh seven six six five eight Oh,
you are?
Yeah.
Oh,
I thought you,
you're six foot six foot.
Yeah.
Perth's barely paying attention to you.
He's like,
he's over there somewhere.
You know that guy.
Well,
congrats on your weight loss.
Thanks man.
I mean it's two 28 January 1st so it's,
it's falling off.
Oh,
that's 96 November 30th and you two 55
no,
two 30 really?
Would you do no bread?
Yeah.
That's a big no fucking bread.
Isn't that an amazing cut out bread and
you will lose a lot of weight.
I mean,
and I've been having beer like it's not
like carbs,
but just no fucking bread.
So crazy.
Have you ever thought about what it'd be
like if you cut it all out?
All carbs?
Yeah,
I think I'd be a boring as fuck.
Oh,
I think it'd be boring.
Just ay man.
Ay I read.
Makes you awesome.
No,
but I think the thing,
I think the thing about like the thing I
like about my personality,
well the thing I like about life I like
about life is just going is,
is impulse.
I love impulse.
I love,
I know it's tough.
When you're on a diet,
you'd be shocked when you've been
groomed on this lifestyle,
how often you just go to the fridge and
open it.
Cause that's what mpulse provides is
like how often you go to get a snack and
like wait,
oh fuck,
I can't snack like in.
So it's,
it's interesting to pull that part of
your personality back.
Then the last part of my personality is
like,
I don't know if like a good opportunity
shows up and someone wants to do a shot,
I wanna be able to do a shot.
So like I think that cutting out all
carbs together,
we'll just be tough for me.
What about just [inaudible] out beer and
just doing like vodka or something?
Cause this isn't a beer way worse for
you then.
I did that.
I did that during this whole time I've
cut out beer entirely,
but uh,
definitely a lot.
A lot of calories,
a lot of calories.
I was doing like I was kinda slow roll
in wine mostly and then do a little
rolling wine.
Yeah.
Is that another expression that I'm not
aware of?
I see a slow wine roller.
Brian,
sometimes when I have a box of wine that
I carry rounds,
I'm a slow modeling wine is the
best inventions in the rooms as you buy
it from Napa drive up there.
When I drink wine I would always drink
like,
like as if it's a normal beverage.
Like it's,
so that's the best way to get drunk.
When we were doing so on,
but we were doing trip flip on the road,
uh,
the last season I was,
I was going through like a box of wine a
night and I was like,
why do we have any wine?
Do we see if we have any one young guy?
I was going through a box of wine at
night and then I told my buddy Paul,
I go,
he goes,
man,
I gotta be honest with you.
A box of wine at night.
I think that's my,
that's my limit.
I will not,
I'm going to try to stay under that and
I'll be healthy.
He goes to the store,
a lot of wine.
I go,
yeah,
like on paper.
And he goes to bottles is a lot.
They go,
these are two bottles.
Okay.
I think it's more than to wait the
fucking minute.
You,
you really just said a box of wine at
night.
It's not that much.
I hit was under the impression it was
one bottle of wine.
So I'm sitting there going like bottle
of wine by yourself.
You don't think that's a lot of alcohol
and it's not a Bach one.
Ivanhoe.
I've had this conversation with doctor
drew.
I don't see a bottle of wine.
There's a lot of alcohol.
Personally,
I've had this conversation with doctor
because everyone always says the same
thing.
You're fucking say prefacing it with
that.
I look at wine,
there's a little differently then like
unrealistic.
If you said,
if you said to me,
what would you rather have a 12 pack of
beer,
uh,
bought a bottle of wine or a bottle of
vodka I got by one's grown up.
You sit back.
Yeah,
maybe like one.
I like the flavor,
the taste,
but I can't imagine if I drank a bottle
a day,
I wouldn't be freaking out.
This is a big conversation to have man.
Like people get upset if one person
expects other people to be healthy.
You know,
you get upset if you try to impose your
healthiness on them.
Like if people were working out and they
have a friend that doesn't work out,
come on,
let's get to the gym,
go to the gym.
Me People don't want to hear that shit.
Never do.
And it's a fine line.
You dance when you're on a podcast where
you want to talk about like fitness and
fitness goals you're doing and then give
advice to friends.
Like maybe try like this because people
will get upset cause it,
we all know that we probably should be
eating better and we all like say one
day I'm going to really fucking do this.
One day I'm going to start blending
vegetables in the morning and stop
eating honey nut cheerios with fucking
chocolate milk.
You know?
Listen gentlemen,
anyone that is a fan of mine right now
that listening to my podcast is,
knows what back exactly what I'm going
to tell you.
Hello Gentlemen.
Cheers.
By the way.
I can I tell you there's two different
kinds of boxes of wine typically,
and there's a smaller one and the more
normal one,
like their friend Xero or whatever it's
called.
Oh this is delicious.
The smaller ones,
smaller bottling,
the smaller ones,
four bottles of wine.
The typical box of wine is six and two
thirds of the bottles.
I was on the road,
I was in Africa.
I don't know what it was.
The road you were drinking four bottles
of wine at night?
No,
it wasn't drinking four bottles.
I don't look like a pirate.
The other thing I'll say is that I
drink,
usually when I have my bottle of wine,
I have it on the treadmill.
So what the fuck did you just say?
I drink.
You drink a bottle of wine while you're
on the treadmill?
Yeah.
All right bro.
You need to go to someone.
Know this.
Listen,
you can't drink wine on the fucking
treadmill because it's you smoked pot
and go to Jujitsu.
That is a totally different thing.
Leaning Bullshit.
Why?
Same Bullshit.
Cause it does.
First of all,
it's not alcohol.
Alcohol is bad for your body.
Marijuana is not bad for your body.
In fact it's an anti inflammatory but
it's cardio.
You're smoking and then what any effect
in your cardio.
In fact,
it probably has a positive benefit.
ultra marathon runner smoke pot,
they smoke pot and eat pot and there's
been studies that have been done
recently.
There's Bert,
oh my drinking a beer on the treadmill.
There's basic study,
find that and by the way,
beer not a bad thing to drink after you
work out a beer.
It replenishes the body with glycogen
according to some people because the
alcohol and the hops,
like some people say that after a nice
workout.
A beer is not a bad thing to have.
Lance Armstrong said that on your
podcast did it?
They used to drink beer.
That was their steroid back in the 20s
or the front.
So the tour de France wine too.
They just say get fucked up cause they
were sore and in pain all to know it
was,
it was,
it was.
It would lower your blood it within your
blood out so you could,
it was like a dopamine.
It was the same thing as doping.
Theoretically it was low grade doping if
I'm not mistaken because I was really
fascinating.
Your blood out dude.
You want to do the opposite.
You want to thicken it a yeah,
maybe I was wrong.
Yeah,
you definitely don't want to think blood
out like you don't want to be
dehydrated.
You want to be extra hydrated.
It's just the opposite.
For me,
it was a way to drink,
relax at the end of the night,
watch some TV,
get on my treadmill,
listen to a podcast,
put on Youtube and get on the treadmill
and just kinda walk in a four and have a
bottle of wine.
Well listen,
it's way better than not walking on the
treadmill and just drinking the bottle
of wine.
Okay.
Then we can agree to disagree.
Yeah.
I mean I think it's way better than not
doing the treadmill.
Yeah,
for sure.
But lets a lot of wine.
I'm not drinking it every single night.
How many nights a week?
Five.
This is feels like an intervention,
but honestly,
how many nights a week did I drink wine?
Yeah.
Well,
right now it's bad because I'm on the
road.
So it would just be Thursday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
those nights he drank several bottles
of,
no,
but I'm doing standup.
So I go on the stage.
I have a cocktail.
It's,
I'm not as dialed in as like,
I'm never going to be able to just tell
you I have one bottle.
I'm not like a housewife.
I might have one bottle of wine at
night.
I was like,
I'm on the road all the time.
So like I'll drink on the road sometimes
and when I'm home I don't drink,
but I was like,
I didn't drink last.
Oh,
I drank a little bit last night,
but it just seems like a stunning
number.
Four bottles of wine at night,
if that's the same size boxes he's
talking about that and your blood sugar
must be out of control from all that
wine,
blood sugar,
uh,
is,
it's probably a little out of sync
because I noticed that,
I noticed that if I have like a cup of
coffee the next morning I start firing
real hot.
Like almost like mannequins.
It's pretty awesome.
You write really good when your blood
sugar spiking?
I do.
Can we just talk about Stan hope you can
talk about anything but the fact that it
makes you uncomfortable talking about
your wine consent rights.
Yes.
I Dunno.
We'd love you.
We want you to be healthy.
I'm dude,
I've lost a ton of weight.
My blood pressure is great.
I'm doing a lot better than I was doing.
So like I'm,
I'm on the right path.
Do you think that doing this travel
channel show where you're constantly on
the road all the time,
it makes it worse?
Yeah,
I would think of what,
because you,
you don't really like flying either.
She liked to get liquored up before
flights.
Yeah.
And so those flights to Vietnam were
pretty tough.
I wish that I was,
I wish there was a guy that could eat
pills,
but I'm not that guy.
I heard Vietnam is awesome.
That's Anthony Bourdain's favorite place
to visit.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And I'll say this to anyone listening.
If you got 13 friends and you guys want
to have an amazing fucking week of your
life,
take coach seats to Vietnam cheap and
just go to how long bay?
Get a junk boat and just go round.
It is,
it's super inexpensive to build a junk
boat and they're beautiful.
They're fully captained and staff.
Do you have your own chef?
And they should change the name of junk
boat if it's that nice.
I know they're beautiful talking.
Just like pull up a pit pit.
Just type in Vietnamese junk boat and
you'll see they're gorgeous.
They're gorgeous.
All teak.
Like they sleep 13 and it was $800 a
night.
How many ex pats are there?
Uh,
uh,
a few.
A bunch.
I would say.
I think you could do a show.
A standup show.
Oh yeah,
100%.
That's the Junco dude look like a pirate
ship.
And that is crazy.
Game of thrones ship 800 bucks a night.
And that's how long bay,
but he's in right there.
Wait a minute.
That's 800 bucks a night for everyone on
board.
Nope.
Just one.
Just for everyone's asleep.
Star slept 13 it was $800 a night.
It's 800 bucks combine.
Yup.
That's insane.
Joe.
That that includes food and all crew.
How safe is it?
100% say if it's a bay,
it's not,
you're not going,
it's just all cliffs and mountains.
It's really gorgeous.
Wow.
And what is crime like in Vietnam?
Oh,
it's up there.
Yeah.
Like you don't go out late at night and
I know you don't like,
you know,
just the thing about Vietnam that I
witnessed her,
I experienced was that like if you get
in a fight with one Vietnamese dude,
hundred Vietnamese guys were jumping on
top of you.
Like that was the who got in a fight,
one of the x,
one of the ex pats that was running.
One of the things we did,
he said,
I was like,
I wanted to go and get these egg
sandwiches,
have these great egg sandwiches,
did the most amazing sandwiches I've
ever had.
And I was like,
I'm going to go run out.
I'm going to get 10 of them.
And he goes,
well bring someone with you.
Well cause it was like,
they're like 50 cents each and the lady
makes them in like a home,
like a hot dog cart.
And she made it.
Dude,
they're the best.
And I have my whole crew with me so I'll
get them for everyone.
Oh,
okay.
What was in them?
Uh,
egg,
shredded pork and uh,
I don't think cheese,
no cheese because Vietnamese don't
really fuck around with cheese.
With a hot sauce.
Yeah.
I don't think there was cheese,
but the eggs were cooked perfectly and
the,
the bread was so soft and flaky and it
was hollowed out and center.
So when the egg fell apart all it did
was just kind of melts into the bread.
So you had like,
it was just the best sandwich I've ever
had in my life.
I think they're called [inaudible] and
uh,
I went out to go get 10 and the guy
goes,
bring someone with you.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm just going to go right across the
street.
And he's like,
it doesn't matter if,
say if you get into some altercation
cause you cutting someone in front of
someone in traffic.
Like the big thing with traffic there is
you don't run across the street.
You walk,
even if they're coming at you walk so
they can avoid you.
You never change your pace.
So if you change your pace,
that's how they hit you.
Oh Christ.
Yeah.
And he's like,
and if you do that and you get a fight,
you literally have 50 Vietnamese guys on
you.
And he was like,
and it,
it happens.
And it happened to me like two weeks
ago.
I got in a fight with one guy and just,
I mean everyone,
like store owners were dropping their
aprons and jumping on this guy.
He said,
whoa.
So yeah,
but I don't think it's,
I don't think it's crime ridden,
but it's not,
it's not fucking Montana.
It's amazing how quickly they forgave
Americans.
They sort of just like,
it probably didn't forget kids.
I don't know.
I mean I don't think it's like Japanese.
Like,
I think the older Japanese folks
apparently just are still pretty pissed
off.
The ones that were alive when they
dropped the bombs.
Yeah,
yeah.
I can see that.
I can see that it's fairly reasonable.
No Japanese,
it's,
it's a very fascinating culture because
they're,
they're openly nationalistic,
you know,
like you could say it's racist,
but it's openly nationalistic.
Like they just like no white people.
They'll have bars,
just no white people.
Oh,
you can't come in.
Could you imagine if someone tried to do
that in America?
You had to say no foreigner.
She put up an like,
is that the Donald Trump America?
Like they'll put up a no foreigners sign
in front of certain establishments.
And some will argue that they have the
right to do that.
There's a drinking club,
uh,
like a drinking club on once.
It's like,
called the Soho Room or something.
It's on sunset,
down near the argo.
What used to be the argyle,
it's like a drinking club.
And they were like,
hey,
we're setting a meeting,
a general meeting with a this writer for
you.
And I was like,
oh,
cool.
And they're like,
you gotta be a member,
he's a member and then he'll let you in.
But it's meant as members only and I was
like,
oh cool.
And I rolled up and my manager judy was
there and I go,
what are you doing here?
She was like,
I'm in the meeting.
I was like,
oh they let women in here cause I just
to zoom that was this like old men's
only club.
She's like,
what fucking world have you been living
in it?
You just shocked that they let women in
and I was like,
oh.
In my head I was like,
well this please place doesn't seem as
cool anymore.
We shut it.
Let a man,
is there a place where there's no
place where they don't let women.
There's places where you don't let men.
Those curves places,
those places where the older ladies like
to work out.
I guess what is,
it's overweight people,
right?
Yeah.
Oh is it overweight people were all
women.
I think it's just all women.
All women have curves.
There's places that are,
is that if I,
am I getting the right name?
Because there's places that are just all
women gyms.
Is that what it's called?
It's called crow.
You couldn't go there?
No,
but you can never have a Dick Swinger's
club.
Like with only men.
Could you have an all men,
Jim?
No.
No one ever let you.
I think you could probably do that or
don't think you're good.
And I think the argument would be they,
the argument they would make,
I'm not saying it's right,
would be that women get sexually
harassed and our gold at a regular gym
and they get uncomfortable and they
don't,
they don't want to have to deal with
men.
They just want to work out.
They could probably add a bar,
have it called no broads or whatever and
like just have like the line that most
bars have where they're like,
ah,
no,
we were only letting the women in
tonight,
you know?
And I say only lifting,
only let them in.
And they could probably easily do that.
I don't think it's against the law.
I don't want him there.
Very good.
No,
I'm good.
I'll leave it over here.
Brian.
Alternate Gloria.
All right.
Would fucking come after you or one of
those well was a,
yeah,
they can't,
they don't have anything like that.
I grew up in a,
I feel like I grew up in a time when
you'd go to the men's locker room where
the bar was,
where they'd all,
all the men.
We'll play cards as a kid at like
country clubs and you'd walk in and
you'd be like one day and then Saturday.
That was all taken away before I could
ever get there.
There's no real place like a Bachelors
Club,
you know?
That's what pool halls used to be.
Yeah.
Pool halls was like what?
What,
what pool halls were at the turn of the
century in New York City.
It was like,
and then a lot of places in the country
where these places where young men who
didn't want family,
they wanted the bachelor life.
They didn't want to have a nine to five
job and know some square life.
They wanted to have action and they
wanted to gamble and they wanted to
drink and they wanted to stay together
and just be men and they would go to
pool halls and they would gamble.
And pool halls were almost entirely,
almost entirely revolved around
gambling,
which is a like a little known secret.
Like the game is called billiard pocket
billiards,
but it's called pool because you pool
your money together for a bet.
That's the original name as the
definition of the name pool.
Really?
Yeah.
So at the turn of the century in New
York City,
there was something like a thousand pool
halls and there was all these guys that
just didn't want to do it.
They didn't want to get married,
they didn't want a nine five job.
They wanted to live the bachelor life.
And today that's like disgraced.
If you want to be a bachelor,
if you want to be a 50 year old guy and
live by yourself,
you never had kids and you don't have a
regular job.
You just said hang out in a pool hall.
The time you're a fucking loser.
It's amazing.
But you could have the same amount of
money,
have a wife that you don't really like
being around,
you know,
be trapped in some weird job and people
think you're a winner.
You know you'd have the same amount of
money.
It's like it's,
we have standards and one of the
standards is a bunch of men that don't
want to be a part of society.
You don't want to have a nine to five
job,
you better be some outdoor dude cause
you know you've been a camper or
something.
If you wanna like get by and normal
conversation with people and tell them
that you're,
you're not married and you don't have a
nine to five job and you don't really
care for that,
but you're 49 years old,
you better have some reason.
Like he's,
he's really eccentric.
He writes poetry and the woods like chef
to have fucking something that you do
that people consider like a noble quest
if you like.
You know what I like to do?
I like smoking cigarettes or like
drinking whiskey.
I like being around my friends.
Sometimes I say open up money.
I get a hooker.
People were like,
what the fuck?
They'll get angry at you.
He'll get angry.
Fucking loser is fucking,
you want to be like this loser.
He doesn't have a family sleeps till
whenever he wants.
Hangs out with a bunch of guys and
laughs all night.
Fucking loser.
I remember hearing someone right when I,
right before I fell in love with my
wife.
I remember seeing someone at the Improv
going,
man,
you know
I want to be the old guy at the bar,
and I went.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
I was hanging out with ron white the
other night.
It was great.
Yeah.
The old guy at the bar was awesome.
Yes.
We had a couple of drinks.
We had some labs.
What do you pull them up,
Jamie?
What's going on?
Breaking news club.
What about like a elk's lodge or at
nights at Columbus or even exist?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they do.
I've got an offer to be in one of those
one time.
Yeah,
but I mean is it all guys?
Girls go like a Latin shriners,
they're called a fraternal groups.
I mean fraternal means looking at that
picture.
I could tell how it smells in that room.
It would almost be fun to hang out with
those old guys.
Just hear them all.
Drop end bombs nonstop.
Me,
the fucking hat.
Can we just agree when you become 60
years old,
you don't want to wear that stupid hat.
They're wearing a hat like a monkey
that's begging for change.
One of them on the monkey with the
grind.
No,
they have the mother hat with the tassel
little monkeys.
They always do that.
Right?
Whatever happened to the Friar's club.
Well it was a big thing in New York and
it's a big thing with guys like,
you know loves it.
He's like Jeff Ross loves it.
Yeah,
I don't,
I never got it.
It's Fitzsimmons used to like it in New
York.
They used to go there and play pool.
It'd be cool if it was a,
if they had like a,
if they had like a legit pool,
you could play poker and know that there
was like a Thursday night poker game if
you go to,
well that was a lot of the things,
the same thing and a lot of ways his
guys looking to hang out with other guys
I was looking to be,
this is a certain amount of society that
just demands circulate to you and having
a regular job where you have to,
you know,
and it's just when you have to wear a
fucking tie and a suit,
you're right away.
You're doing something.
You don't want to do your dressing in a
way that you would never dress if you
were just left to your own devices,
right?
You've got a tie and a suit and a
fucking one of those pockets scarf
things and you have to go to work.
You can't swear and you're there all day
and your feet hurt because you get a
wooden heel walking around a wooden heel
and a fucking hard leather of soul,
like a stupid shoe that you have to
wear.
And you've got a tie clip and you're
fucking,
you have to bullshit on the phone and
you have to pretend to be someone that
you're not all day long.
That when you have to pretend to not be
a guy who likes pussy or not be a guy
likes to party or swear or you,
you have to like neuter yourself in a
lot of ways.
And in doing so over long periods of
time,
especially when you rewarded for that,
you're rewarded for it at work or you're
exemplary conduct.
You know,
he's got a great bedside manner.
He's got,
he's got a wonderful office,
manners,
you know,
you,
you fucking slow.
It's slowly start to chip away at you.
You still,
you start to slowly become something
that you're not really and you don't,
you don't get a chance to express
yourself and you get a few hours at the
end of the day to have a couple of
drinks and go to sleep and do it all
over again and you'll reset period that
you get over the weekend.
It's not enough time,
dawn of time.
And if you had a year to be yourself
again and just be around your friends
and you just,
you guys could just behave and think the
way you really feel,
laugh at shit.
You actually think it's funny but fuck
around with each other.
That's been a comment.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'll never forget,
I'll never forget me,
you and owl and uh,
we're sitting together talking about
someone you're like,
I can get that kind of suck my Dick and
I'm me and laughed so fucking hard.
And I just thought to myself,
I thought no one lives no like,
because no one lives in that world that
we live in,
that we're all a little fucking toasty.
And you're like,
I can get that kind of suck my Dick and,
and like you can you imagine saying
that?
What was the guy doing?
Who was the guy?
Do you remember?
Yeah.
Okay,
we'll talk later.
I don't remember where it was.
I love being able to say something
totally retarded.
Like to add to my friends.
Cause you like when like Joe Joey will
say like the most fucked up.
Like he'll say fucked up shit on it
stage,
but he'll pull you aside,
who pull you aside and say something
unbelievably fucked up shit that makes
you laugh.
That was one of the things that he was
doing while that fucking the whole cap
rule thing was going on.
I'm going to have you on your current
wife boss suck my Dick.
Yes.
She says dark.
So crazy.
Did he air those still up like the rl,
all those tweets and those are my,
those are some of my favorite calls.
When bonds calls me Tom,
he calls me and he's like,
ah,
have you been following joeys twitter
thread?
And like you literally are cleaning this
sleep out of your,
I was like,
hold on,
let me get it out of my computer.
What's going on?
So fucking Tommy and Tommy,
that's one of them are our biggest,
cause we,
you know,
we started together doing the road
together and one of the favorite things
you,
when you sit in the green room with the
guys,
just kind of bullshit.
I can bullshit with that guy forever.
Forever.
He really is the best.
Such a sweetie.
She's such a great guy.
He's tall as is his wife.
She's awesome man.
I'd might argue that she's funnier than
him.
She's pretty well.
He's fucking hilarious.
He's funny.
He's funny in a way that I,
this is why,
but he's like Joe,
like Joey,
cause I remember watching Tom when he
just this,
you know Tom's hearing this so I know,
you know I love you to death Tommy.
But like there was a time where tom an
oil,
he'll admit this,
that he was trying to figure out how to
do it like a towel and,
and he would just be like,
like his pacing was off and then all of
a sudden something switched on him and
he's telling stories where I can't find
out.
I don't see the setup punch,
but I'm howling.
Fuck Tommy.
They just fucking howling laughing at
him and I'm like bucking.
He is dialed in.
He is in the bees and the sweet spot of
his writing right now.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
What I was going to say was,
he's really fucking funny,
but I know what you're saying cause
she's really fucking funny.
She's hilarious.
She's really,
and they have a kid now,
which is going to be really interesting
because once you have a kid you have a
solid 20 minutes new material.
It's just a matter of like covering over
the same ground that everybody else
covers over.
When you have a kid you have to Kinda
like comb through your material and make
sure none of it has been done before.
It's too as as really hard.
It's hard with like really common shared
experiences that are transformative,
like having a kid or something happened
to you like guys who have cancer that a
lot of times you have similar material
about getting cancer.
I remember Schimmel had a bunch of
cancer bits after he got back from a
cancer airplanes dose.
Those bits have been beaten down so much
that you almost have to have something
fucking catastrophic happened on a plane
for you to do a joke about being on a
plane.
It's like that subject matter,
like people's eyes sort of glaze over if
you go over that because they've heard
playing jokes and travel jokes because
comedians talk about what they do and if
you only travel all the time,
you're doing shows and then traveling.
So like the show,
no one's going to be able to relate to
that.
Like you're doing something weird,
you're talking,
everybody listens.
People pay for that.
What the fuck kind of job was at.
That's just weird for people to relate
to and that's for you.
That's your job,
but your job is also to live because you
have to have things to talk about.
When you get up there,
your job is to Hashtag be curious,
you know,
which is why I was saying to you,
it's kind of crazy that you have this
insane life,
like your life is one of the more
fascinating lives of all my friends
because you travel everywhere.
I fucking called him up one day.
I go,
what are you doing man?
He's like,
I'm on a moped in Vietnam.
I go,
who the fuck can you call?
And they're on a moped in Vietnam.
Like that's your life is crazy.
It's crazy in that way.
You know it's talking about it on stage.
You're going to have so much material
meant once you,
if you stopped doing that show,
if you decide and then you know you do
this hour and then you go to make your
next hour and you start talking about
just the crazy shit you've done.
Oh my,
you have so much time.
I mean I literally right now I'm looking
at this hour and I'm chunking it out and
you know,
my youngest daughter is a very
interesting child so like I've got a
whole chunk about her.
I've got a middle chunk.
I'm in the,
I'm on the fence about,
but it's just,
it's fun stuff.
It's,
it's good.
But then I just literally break to like,
I fought a bear,
I got involved with a Russian mafia and
the net and I'm like,
just get rid of this chunk so I can go.
I drank goat's blood with a messiah
chief.
I fucking had my first open water dive
at 90 feet.
I fucking jumped off the tallest strat.
I jumped off the stratosphere.
I jumped off the like I literally would
Mike Ready to get this hour out so I can
just start writing.
But that's the,
and that's,
I think I'm maybe,
I'm lucky right now because I go,
I'm ready to,
I'm ready to go on the road of figured
the hour out.
I don't need it to murder.
I need to figure it out.
Well the the way to do that is like,
I think is doing these little short sets
around town.
Yeah.
Well you just go up and say for the next
15 minutes I'm going to talk about
drinking blood with the Messiah chief
and we'll fucking see what we can get
out of this.
Yeah,
let's put it on your phone.
Cause I did,
I just,
this last weekend,
a long time ago,
I told you a story and passing and this
is how weird the podcasts are.
He said,
I told you a story and passing that was
a funny,
I thought it was a funny story for me
and you to talk about.
And everyone loved it and they've always
chanted it out at my shows.
I've never been able to tell it.
It's a story about flying dildos going
to the show.
And I never,
it never worked.
And I tried it on stage.
People go do it and I'd be like,
well I'll do,
I'll do it,
but it's not going to work cause it's a
good room for us.
But this last weekend someone yell just
fucking talent.
And so I told it and it worked and I
figured out the ending.
That's the best feeling in the world
when you're like,
okay,
now I've got my beginning,
my middle of my ending,
now I've got to figure out that middle
guts and I can get through this.
Holy Shit.
And then I'm like,
all right,
let's get April 1st,
let's get this hour done.
I'm ready to fucking write.
Like I'm ready to powerful Paul fucking
man.
Very excited.
Eyes are wide,
very excited.
I'm gonna stand up mode,
man.
Good,
beautiful fuck.
It's the greatest feeling in the world.
It's the reason you get into this.
And then this business takes over
somehow and says,
now it doesn't.
You let it,
you have to let it.
Don't let it take over.
I ain't need money.
You know the feeling,
but you make money.
I know,
but money doing standup too.
Yeah.
But I wasn't making money doing stand up
the way I'm making it now.
Six years ago.
Mm.
What about podcasts?
Do you have good ads and your podcasts?
Make good money on my podcast.
I wouldn't say I make like what you were
crawling make,
but like at all.
But good money,
like a definitely good money.
Like enough to pay for?
Uh,
maybe a couple of cars.
Okay.
I'm trying to guess.
I don't know what I dunno,
like that's very specific,
very specific domestic cars.
Uh,
fully loaded.
Um,
uh,
for this expedition in a [inaudible].
So tell me about your stan hope trip is
the best decision I ever made in my
grownup life.
Yeah.
Yep.
How would you do I just,
what'd you decide?
I'd card set on podcasts with you.
I'd said I wanted to go out there for
the super bowl and it didn't work out
because I did a podcast with crawl on
Monday and I wouldn't be able to make it
back.
And I felt bad.
I felt like I didn't get,
I was like,
cause I really love,
I really love dog.
I think he's one of the sweetest guys
around.
So I just called him up one day.
I go,
hey you mind if I come out like just to
hang out for a day and party.
And he was like,
I'm fucking here,
Lewis do it.
So I just tagged it on to one of my
trips and I did like,
I've been doing like theater,
not theater but like a single club.
Then weekend,
then single club.
I just canceled the single club
throughout to Doug's Chelsie picked me
up at the airport,
rolled in.
Everyone's in the fun house drinking
bingos in there.
It's fucking amazing.
I think we podcasted for six hours
nonstop,
unedited.
Ma.
I'm telling you when I say the open,
my opus of podcasting is just me and
doug talking shit about everybody.
Just fucking tearing apart.
Art terrapower Park,
good comedy,
tearing apart life.
His Buddy Chad shanks there.
Tash hilarious.
Doug's podcast is one of my favorite
ones to listen to because it's,
it is a real authentic extension of his
personality.
The same way this is for you.
That is what you do.
When I first started listening to
podcasts,
I go,
this is what Joe does.
He gets all nine at the end,
the night smokes a joint and just
research is most important.
Shit it most crazy insane shit and now
he's just telling us about it.
Oh this is fucking amazing.
Oh now he's bringing the people that he
finds online.
He's bringing them in and having a
conversation with them.
This is great.
This is Doug.
Just start drinking a four fucking vod
cause with a bartender and is fun.
Have you ever been out to his compound?
Nope.
Oh,
it's fucking amazing.
Hello.
How far is it from the airport and the
drive?
About an hour and a half.
And he's Charlie's his tour manager.
Would it bt to drive from la I think six
hours.
Six to eight from here.
60th his place.
Six to eight I think.
Yeah,
six days.
That's not bad.
I typed in my address on accident and
gave me directions.
It's seven miles from the Mexico border.
We roll in.
That's crazy.
And Doug is literally just,
and you know man,
it's like,
you know Douglas say this but like he
doesn't get to hang out with comics
cause he lives in the middle of nowhere.
So he rolled in,
he was in his pajamas,
never changed out of his pajamas,
just smiling ear to ear and smoking a
cigarette and he's like,
oh what can I get you to drink?
And literally off the bat we start
podcasting and just catching up.
I was fucking,
this is his fun house.
So what is the fun house?
Why does he call it the fun?
So he's got five think he's got four
properties,
four houses on this property.
He's got the main house,
he's got the maybe as like seven,
I don't know.
But he's like,
there's a bunch of like trailers around
that people can live in.
And then he's got an a guest house that
I stayed in and he's got another house
that Chalian his wife Tracy stay in and
their buys houses in the neighborhood.
They're like 35 grand.
What?
He just keeps buying them.
When the people bought the house for 35
grand going to Detroit.
You can buy.
Just keeps by.
Yeah,
but we're not talking about Detroit.
We're talking about Bisbee.
He buys them.
Just keeps buying them and he's,
and he's got corrugated metal fence.
Can't see over it.
So it's all around 35 Grand Detroit and
get it for like 500 right?
Yeah,
but it's still busy in the middle of
nowhere.
No one wants to move there.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
It's where you're wrong.
I let me tell you something.
I shot a Vlog for this.
You're like,
you know,
I've been doing my blogs.
Why bring my camera out to do my Vlog?
I liked how you say it cause nobody else
says it.
Everybody else will write it,
but they don't say it.
Oh really?
I never heard anybody saved blog.
Am I saying it wrong?
No,
you're saying that totally rocking it,
but it's something that people write.
They write down,
you know,
like Vlog for the day.
Nobody says it.
Know what to call idea blog.
Right.
Did you ever hear anybody saved Vlog?
Now Brian is as entrenched in the
culture.
I mean,
it's probably the right thing to say.
I just never,
I've seen it written.
I just never heard anybody say it other
than,
you know,
he's addicted to vlogs.
I found out he just want,
knows all of the youtubers.
But I had shaylee bring me into,
uh,
into Bisbee and I shot,
I shot b roll of busy.
It's beautiful.
Really beautiful.
Right,
right,
right outside tombstone where they'll
kick,
how corollas went to tombstone rolled
in.
And Man,
it ended.
I have a vlog out posted.
I have to edit it.
This is a cave for sale out there.
I met the two people that live in it.
So Dope House man.
Uh,
I met the two people who live in it.
The like hobbit people.
Yeah.
To live in a hobbit house.
Like it's a cave.
Yeah,
it's,
it was amazing.
And I told Doug,
I said,
you need to have more people come out
here and do this because it was so fun,
man.
It was so fun.
Like we,
we were,
we ended up just singing at the end,
just partying and singing songs and,
oh,
so fucking great.
And Yeah.
And so that podcast right now,
uh,
his girlfriend has gone awol or his
wife's gone awol,
so yeah.
She's got a wall.
Yeah.
Uh,
he's talked about on this podcast,
so I'm not sharing cave house.
Is this the cave house in Bisbee?
Look at this.
Oh,
though I didn't meet these people then.
hello.
Hey Katherine Clark.
This is my home.
You that gate.
Oh,
so it's dug into the side of the house.
Yeah.
Is this the same place?
This is in Bisbee Jamie.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at that.
It's got a dope fucking little forest
behind it.
And this waterfall and shit did that
does not what Doug's compound.
It looks like.
This is awesome.
If I moved to Bisbee,
I'd buy this for me.
I kept saying to myself,
they've got a theater in there that doug
does.
This is nuts.
Look at this.
These people have,
oh my God,
that's gonna be so cool as fucking
house.
If it's like,
yeah,
right.
Why cold?
Cause you're going to cave in Mexico.
I know,
but it's,
it's cave.
It's rockets or hot down there.
It's the desert.
You think that's hot in their old?
Yeah.
Oh,
I think being in the cable be cold no
matter where you are.
Cooler,
right?
Yeah.
But still it's 140 degrees outside.
It's not cool in there.
It might be.
If it's like a base,
the house is fucking bad ass.
I want to live there,
man.
I bet you'd get it for 125 I bet you
couldn't.
I bet that house has at least a million
bucks.
1.5
million.
Is that what it says?
Hello?
By the way,
I'm looking at 1.5
million of these days.
It doesn't look like that.
Yeah.
Right.
So no 1.5
million gets you
in La.
His who?
A regular house.
Three bedroom.
Three bath.
Yeah.
Isn't it crazy?
When we were kids,
he thought of someone who had $1 million
is being like the most unbelievably rich
set for life.
And then you hear someone's house cost
$1 million.
You're like Holy Shit.
Million Dollars.
Yeah.
And then you look at what $1 million
buys you in La and you're like,
what?
Yeah.
How about,
what would it buys you in New York City?
You're,
we'll look at that.
No.
Oh my God.
The missus and I looked at fucking
apartments in New York City at one point
in time,
just on a whim,
man.
I just get these ideas in my head like I
don't want to live in the same place
forever.
I like to move around and I'm thinking
maybe I should buy an apartment in New
York.
We'll just try living in New York for a
few months,
so like 5 million bucks for like a 1600
square foot apartment.
I was like,
this is nuts.
I got,
I got back probably larger than that,
but I got back from Doug's and went
right back,
right back with my wife and her best
friend,
her buddy,
her husband's a movie guy.
He's got money and they were like,
let's get a compound compound.
Where would you do it though?
I'm being dead serious.
I could totally do it in Bisbee,
but would you want to do in Brisbane?
I don't,
I wouldn't want to.
I'd like to do it with it.
With some fan.
Do you want to be that close to Mexico?
I would like to do it maybe in like in
like Montana,
Alabama,
Georgia,
Montana.
Now you're talking like Colorado
Cock,
Colorado Cock Cock Colorado.
I slow rolled that one.
Colorado will be tough I think because
of the elements.
Oh,
don't be a pussy.
It's all white people.
What are you talking about?
What elements?
You're talking about black people.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Remember that Brian in Atlanta,
we're in Atlanta.
We're talking to this racist white girl
and she,
she was like,
well you don't want to go to that club.
I go,
why?
She goes,
well,
you know the elements like the hangout
there.
What?
What the fuck?
What the fuck to say?
The elements.
So we looked at each other.
I could hold the hell.
What does that even mean?
But we both kind of knew what shoes I
go.
Explain yourself.
What are you saying?
She's like,
well,
black people,
no shot.
Oh,
the elements.
The elements like fucking earth,
wind and fire.
The element.
It's so weird when you said elements
too.
I'm like,
wait a second.
I can't believe you just said that.
You remember?
Yeah.
You remember that girl?
She was way out in the open with their
racism.
She's like,
y'all are,
why come on,
you know,
he know about the elements.
Y'All don't wanna be around the
elements,
especially when it gets dark out.
You can't see who trump.
Did you watch that video?
Yeah.
Dirt or whatever.
What is he the,
the daily show video where it shows that
nothing.
None of you saw this.
No,
no.
I'll keep going.
But everybody's saying that word drunk.
Drunk,
but I didn't know what it meant.
It's a,
it's this guy who's,
I was not the daily show,
but it's the other guy.
Uh,
John Oliver.
John Oliver did a breakdown,
a Donald Trump the other day on his show
and it was one of the most beautiful
things ever.
It was.
So they found
out that hit like trump's real name,
like his great grandfather changed it to
trump.
Uh,
but it was originally drum for whatever
dirt or whatever it was.
Cough.
Yeah.
Trump's not bad.
What's wrong with drums?
I'm Bert.
Fuck.
Who gives a fuck?
Joe,
you want me Goddamn or are Brian Man.
Yeah.
All right.
I gotta I gotta say this.
You say that,
but you change your fucking last name.
Well,
my,
my age racist.
How dare you were scared of your Nazi
past now.
But Brian,
there's people my age.
There are so many brians because it
Brian's song came out the year I was
born,
so everyone named their kid Bryan
because that fucking movie.
Yeah.
Really?
Is that what the s is that what
happened?
She said Hell Trey Songz got his name.
Who's Trey Songz dumb joke though.
I thought only Brian.
We got trey Songz.
I got to say this real quick cause
sheerly just emailed me.
I think it's doug in them are watching
this.
Uh,
hold on.
So,
uh,
so some drama happened on this trip.
Oh,
uh,
this,
Doug's talked about it and they just
released the second podcast dealing with
this.
I think they found Bingo.
So,
uh,
so Bingo is Doug's wife,
live in wife.
She was supposed to take me to the
airport in the morning and she was like,
and tugs,
don't worry,
she'll get you up at like eight.
She gets him at six 30 and like combat
boots and ready to roll a,
he'd go someone and uh,
and uh,
get in the car with her.
She drives me to the airport and then
like halfway through she says,
uh,
I'm running away.
And I was like,
I'm fucking hung over shit.
I'm like,
I don't know how to deal with this
information.
And I'm like,
do I ask style Doug Doug running or
cult?
No.
I should have to run away.
Yeah.
Succumbed Syndrome.
So bingo started,
started dating some guy that lives in
the woods.
I heard about all this.
Yeah.
And so it's got an outhouse.
Outhouses.
One for his bird is owls.
Yeah.
Guide.
And so,
uh,
she's like,
don't tell Doug,
don't tell Shaylee.
Don't tell anyone.
I'm just disappearing.
Obviously you didn't abide by that fuck.
No,
I was called Doug immediately.
I was like,
I woke him up.
Bingo.
Ran Away.
And so like,
it was,
it was pretty serious.
I think it was [inaudible] with Doug.
Everything's,
there's a joke,
like everything is lighthearted.
What,
did you ever listen to the podcast with
him and her when she was talking about
ending ending this thing,
this experience called life?
Yeah,
that's why I called Doug.
I was like,
I can't let this.
She's like,
just,
just don't tell dog.
Don't tell anyone.
I appreciate it.
Give me a big hug.
Got It all on my blog.
I'm not,
yeah,
I'm not fucking problem.
Not that would never share anything like
that.
I saw I got to sing as tearful.
Goodbye.
Cause I was like,
in my head I'm like,
I don't know how this is going to end
for Bingo because I know that she says
that.
So I called Doug immediately wake him up
and I was like,
Bingo.
Ran Away.
He was like,
what?
He knew she ran away halfway through in
the ride because he's like,
hey,
you left your phone and you took
blankets.
And then she was like,
cause he called me on my phone and he
was,
and she was like,
yeah,
yeah.
I thought burt wanted to sleep in the
car halfway through.
I'm like,
oh,
I could sleep in this fucking car.
Like I should have gone to sleep.
And then I looked back,
I see coolers and like all gear,
like it's all packed and my bags and I'm
like,
fuck.
So I called Doug Call Shaylee.
So then Doug,
I say that I told some secrets,
maybe that shouldn't have said to doug,
but one of the things mango,
say she wanted this guy and doug to kind
of meet and figure out what she should
do.
So it was like,
she wants you to podcast and do it
well.
Whoa,
whoa.
She wanted doug to podcast with her new
boyfriend and figuring out what she
should do.
Yeah.
So wow.
So strong psych meds.
So I tell Doug and so literally he calls
me like as at my plane lands and he's
like,
we're podcasting right now.
So that podcast just got released
yesterday and I think th just texted me
the new podcast.
We're bingo calls in I guess just got
released right now.
No,
they're not.
Just some dude.
I know hall somewhere.
I sat in the car with her man.
Oh there's so many.
Uh,
it's,
it's uh,
it was intense,
but you know,
doug takes everything was such a pace.
Such like a Lego.
Yeah.
Well fuck it.
I'll bring bath,
tub willie in his,
what he calls him and I'll do a podcast
with bath tub willie.
Yeah.
And I told Doug,
I go,
hey dude,
don't say that anything opening of the
podcast is so cries.
Your calls me,
tells me Bingo ran away.
So a,
that
pizza.
So sad.
When you see someone who you in your
mind,
like you have the memory of them being
like real happy.
Like when I think of Bingo,
I think of Bingo hanging out with doug
at shows and it's always,
we're laughing.
We're all laughing.
Yeah.
So that's my idea of Bingo.
So my idea of a depressed Bingo,
it doesn't make any sense.
I don't,
I don't have it in my,
my,
my accessible memory,
you know what I mean?
Like I've only seen her have a good
time.
I've only seen her having fun and we all
accepted there's ups and downs to being
a person.
There's like highs and lows and you
know,
you get in slumps and you feel like shit
and then you come back and you feel
great.
And it's one of the reasons why you
appreciate those really high spots cause
you remember when you didn't feel so
good but you see someone like Bingo,
like when she was hanging around with
Doug and in my eyes it was always like
dogs.
You got to let Doug Be Doug.
You know.
And Doug's always had a problem with,
you know,
when he was with other chicks there was
always like some sort of a different
kind of drama then like what Bingo
presented being presented crazy.
But she also presented like this
willingness to like have fun and go
along with everything.
And it was perfect for like letting the
best parts of Doug just blossom because
they were so cool together.
Yeah.
And she's crazy.
She's got blue hair and half her head
shaved and she's a mad woman.
Right.
So it was like,
this is great,
this is perfect.
And it was always in my eyes.
All I remember is them smiling and
laughing.
So it's always weird to me.
And even though rationally,
obviously I know that people have their
ups and downs.
When I remember someone who's like
really happy and really laughing and you
know,
like big open smile.
Ah Ha ha.
You know,
throwing her head back laughing.
That's,
that's like the,
these are the thoughts that I have when
I think about like her and doug hanging
out at shows.
I think how,
how,
how does someone forget how to do that?
Like how do you,
how do you stay in that pocket?
How do you,
uh,
how do you stay as close to the fun all
the time.
Pocket is possible without slipping in.
I mean,
is it a chemical thing?
Is it a behavioral thing?
Is it a life circumstances and your
reaction to it thing,
what it,
what is it that brings those downers
man,
where people just feel like utter shit.
Serotonin levels and I guess she has,
you know,
issues.
So like medicine probably that she's
taking mixtures.
Look at brody,
he has ups and downs all the time.
It's,
yeah,
and I mean I did so many people that I,
that I ended up calling crazy almost to
a point.
It seems like it's,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
I feel like could be calling a woman
crazy in the future.
It's going to be the next tranny
transgender.
Like it's like,
it's an alternative thinking,
you know?
But it,
I feel like I just nonstop and it's just
people,
brains,
man.
And people just,
they have ups and downs.
I had fucking ups and downs,
you know,
everyone has so many factors to right.
It's gotta be chemical man.
Cool.
And then there's life,
there's like the curve balls life throws
yet at you.
Like they're undeniable,
that great moments in your life where
things are going great,
you fucking feel great and then what
things are going shitty.
You feel shitty.
That would kind of try to deny that
there's some sort of a correlation
between those two.
But sometimes it's just shitty things
happen.
You know,
like Ari Shaffir just broke his ankle
skin.
That's just a shitty thing that
happened.
And I think the stick,
and I think we don't forget about him
either.
Like,
like,
like if you get in a relationship,
you break up,
you feel like you got over it,
but that still is something in you
that's taxing that you don't even know.
You've actually taken down a couple
levels of happiness.
She was something else.
Like your car,
you get in a car accident that adds on
to it and you don't even realize that
the ground,
that's what's the,
the level of happiness is getting pushed
down deeper and deeper almost.
It's true.
The thing about a Bingo and doug that
really,
like when you were saying,
it's like,
you know,
that's like a,
that's a really like a nuclear family.
Like they try,
you know,
they travel and they all stay in one
room.
Fucking six people stay in one room.
That's not a good move.
No,
but that's,
but that,
you know,
but like that's one of the beauties of
Doug.
I always,
except I always look at other people is
like always glass half full.
That's the cool thing about doug is
that,
you know,
obviously Doug's shows her foot in the
bills for the tour manager,
the manager
for their wives,
their girlfriends,
and it's like this real big family.
And so what was really heartbreaking for
me,
because I hung out with them and I
didn't know anything was wrong at all.
I mean I knew that they were going
through this,
but like we were all hanging out and,
and,
and Bingo is air.
And we were laughing and sing.
And I showed these guys have videos.
I have a moment computer of just,
I mean,
just,
I'm telling you like Saint Elmos Fire
Shit,
like everyone holding arms,
just literally having the greatest time
of my life and I lead how aggressively
fucked up was I at the end of that
video?
How'd yet you're,
you're,
you couldn't even talk on this.
I could not speak St Elmos fire.
It was so great.
And so my whole hope is that,
is that it's gotta be mads,
man.
I'm,
I spend an hour and a half in the car
with her more than x.
We had traffic,
but it's meds.
It's well,
it's just what,
what is going on in your brain versus
another person's brain.
You can only speculate.
So wait,
how about no,
how,
I don't know how anybody else sees the
world,
but how about like,
tell me if you tell me what you think
about this.
Honestly.
Um,
say you put,
um,
say it's a,
I'm trying to think of a scenario where
I could say this end of the world,
we go to an island.
It's a,
it's like you,
your wife and kids,
Brian and some girl to,
he'll,
I end up falling in love with Jamie,
a bunch of computers,
um,
to make those too.
But,
but what you got to pay me?
It's computer.
Oh,
we'll give him a rocket.
The computer.
And why haven't I fallen in love yet?
Cause it's good.
Hear the story.
You're Dominic Monaghan.
My point is,
and there's no meds,
no meds.
Right?
But you got all your favorite people
there.
Okay.
And there's no meds.
And I'm saying like,
do you believe that someone saying maybe
that was on meds that been put in a
perfect scenario?
No.
Apex predators on the island.
It's just family,
friends,
coconuts.
He,
everyone's feeling good.
They're eating healthy people.
Do you believe,
cause I wonder sometimes,
do you believe then that all those
problems is society slid in where you
now are on Prozac or whatever?
Uh,
do you think that they would be pulled
away and that person will go like,
man,
I'm,
I'm feeling good,
I'm eating healthy.
I got one job.
It's just to go get coconuts in the
morning.
I get my coconut,
we all sit by the pool or by the,
I don't know man.
I think there's a real danger.
What do you hold your hand up?
What does that say?
It's a Dominic Monaghan joke.
How he was awesome and that thought too
and he was fucking amazing.
This is a real danger.
And in sand it's either or,
you know?
Have you ever taken meds?
No,
but I think for some people they're
really important.
But do you feel like marijuana's
sometimes acts like a,
like a,
like a Zoloft for you?
No.
But marijuana definitely gives you a
more sensitive perspective and a calms
you down and it makes you more connected
to all the other people that you come in
contact with.
It definitely does that in a lot of
ways.
Yeah.
You know,
but it's not what's going on with
people.
They're taking medication that people
that are taking medication like Ssri.
Um,
I've met,
I have some friends that
they started using them and it changed
their life.
You know,
a couple,
quite a few.
And then both of them coincidentally,
or not coincidentally,
but,
um,
after a while they weened off of them
and their life got better and they're
both really smart guys.
And when their life got better,
then they wean themselves off the psych
meds and they stayed happy.
So I think everybody's got a different
story too.
And there's a,
there's a real,
not a danger,
but I think it's a real prejudice that
people do well.
They'll,
they'll decide like it's one way or the
other.
Like it's either you don't need any
medication,
all you need to do is diet and exercise
and run and you'll be fine.
And then there's other people that think
that it's a disease.
The way to treat it is primarily through
medication and that's it.
And your health and your,
um,
you know,
your exercise routines and your diet
really doesn't have any bearing on it
because it's,
there's some sort of a neurological
disorder.
You have an issue with your brain.
So there's people that are under like
that school of thought.
I think the real answer,
if you talk to a lot of those
neuroscientists,
they'll tell you it's somewhere in the
middle.
It's like,
who the fuck knows?
Like I don't know you.
And so you might be completely batshit
crazy and you need medication.
Dude,
you're just fucking wired wrong.
It's not happening in there.
Someone needs to go in there and rewire
shit.
Or you might be a guy who could easily
be healthy.
If he could get on a good roll.
You know,
if you could just get some momentum
going and start,
you know,
getting up in the morning,
drinking warm water with lemon,
getting on the fucking treadmill for a
half an hour every morning,
put that treadmill in the garage,
plug that fucker in every morning just
to fucking half an hour before you go.
Once you start getting on these roles
like that,
you start feeling better.
There's a serotonin drip that happens.
You start feeling better,
you get,
you get more fit,
you get more healthy,
you feel better.
When you feel better,
your brain works better.
Like it's undeniable.
So it's not necessarily one or the
other,
but we don't know.
I don't know what's going on in your
head.
You don't know what's going on in my
And I think that's where it gets weird
when people like these psych meds aren't
helping anybody.
I think some of them might be helping
some people,
some people hit a bad spot man.
And I think the psych drugs can fucking
pull them up.
And then they can get accustomed to
being on balance and then they can get
off of him.
I wish I knew more.
I've always,
they've always told me I should go on a
something for uh,
for anxiety.
You know,
they're like,
oh,
to change your life.
It might,
I might w the wonder about it is what
adult,
what's awesome about your personality?
Hundred percent.
That's what everybody was crazy man.
I think fucking crazy.
Well that's part of what makes you you
and then it's not like you don't have a
handle on it.
It's just slippery.
The handles slippery,
very slippery.
It's covered in mct oil.
It's that way for every one who's
trying to do anything creatively.
You know,
you can't be 100% relaxed.
This is not going to work that way.
Have you been to a therapist before?
I'm in therapy right now.
Hollow is best and I the,
my favorite moment was anytime I,
cause I have a,
I have a lot of epiphanous moment,
you know,
like I have cognitive,
not cognitive and emotional.
That word.
I've been alive 48 years.
Really ever said epiphanous I have,
I have a lot of emotional epiphanous
moment because yeah.
You know,
I had a day where I,
where I jumped off the tallest stadium
in the world,
swim with great white sharks and then
rappelled up at 3000 foot mountain.
So like at the end of that day,
you're sitting there going like the fuck
man.
Like what?
Like what is going through my brain?
Like I survived three times today when
I,
when in the day in deadly activities,
but then I knew that were safe,
but,
and so,
uh,
and then it started happening that I
started getting a very low threshold for
this moment.
It's like,
things can just be like Stan hopes,
man.
I,
I was firing hot,
I was at the airport and I was just
like,
he was one of the greatest times I've
ever had in my life,
I would like.
But I,
and I go,
I wonder if it was the greatest time of
my hand,
my life,
or if I'm just like so connected right
now to whatever that is.
They've got a theater there.
I was gonna say this.
I think Joey,
Ari and I are going to do it 125 seats.
Stan hope presents.
Just go down and spend it in business.
You know he and I talked about that.
I was like,
that theater sounds like the perfect
place it is.
Bring in comics for a weekend.
Fuck yes.
Did you ever do the old cobb's?
Yeah,
I don't know.
Like 150 seats.
No,
it probably might not even been that
many seats.
The old cops was,
I did.
It was down by the wharf.
Yes,
I did it.
What was called the green room.
Oh,
so you did it after it was cops the cops
and move to the new spot.
That was a great fucking club though.
It's crazy because cobbs is like the old
cobb's was literally like the perfect
size club,
but it was almost too small to make
money.
So like if you worked at cobb's,
you got paid less than if you worked at
the punchline,
which is also a great Rome right punch.
I was fantastic.
It was so good about that comms cause he
was so small.
He would go there,
which is like so packed in tight.
I would make less money to work there,
but look forward to it more.
It caught on fire,
right cy?
Yeah.
Something happened man.
There's some sort of a fire really.
They moved to a new spot and the new
spot they moved to as a giant ass spot.
It's hard to,
that was always hard to fill for me.
Not if you're Doug Benson,
but the new spot is still awesome.
It's really like the new spot.
It's really cool but it's weird.
It's got a high ceiling and it's got a
balcony that's way in the back where you
know Doug,
when Doug sells tickets to those,
to that theater and he's done stuff
there.
No one from Bisbee has to hold like 25
tickets for Bisbee residents.
It's all people flying into Tucson and
driving down to go see the show.
That's pretty fucking legit.
Wow.
I was like,
dude,
that is what I was like,
bring out.
I would come in in a heartbeat in a
heartbeat.
My initial idea of coming in was like,
go in,
do standup in like near Bisbee,
see if I can get stand up to look at my
hour,
tell me where I'm being lazy.
But,
and then he was like,
just do it in my house.
Wow.
But like,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I'd love those old small rooms are the
best.
The laughing skull is a great fucking
rape.
Fucking room.
Tiny,
you know,
it's like almost like just a little
bigger than the belly room,
you know,
a hundred seat room to the belly rooms.
Fucking amazing.
You know,
I never fucked around with the store
ever up until like very recently.
That fucking belly room is,
I've fucking why would you ever do the
or or the main room?
I didn't want to,
I'll tell you how little I knew the time
I want them to do Ari storytelling show.
I didn't know which one was which.
I literally had to go in and go,
what is the belly room?
That's how little I did the store.
And they're like,
and the guy didn't even know who I was
and it was like an army brought me up
there.
I mean,
fucking perfect.
Did what's his name's new material
night.
Uh,
Jay just Cya.
Jeremiah,
Jeremiah Watkins,
new material that brain's fucked but
like was old school,
he name it is.
Yeah.
I got it.
Met his mom.
She must have been into the Bible just
like you,
Brian's song.
No,
now ahead.
Thank you Jamie.
But so,
uh,
but like that,
that belly room and I don't,
I'm not a guy that goes out often during
that,
that convinced me to start getting out
in the city.
Are you call it and he's like,
can you do my host,
my storytelling show?
I'm like,
done that belly rooms.
Fucking amazing.
Yes.
It's a weird place.
It's so tucked away.
A little tiny room at the store.
We do weekends there sometimes man.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We do like a Friday night or Saturday
night,
10 o'clock show.
It's just me and friends,
you know.
That's fucking amazing.
I mean the,
the whatever the big one is that we've
dived on that one with you.
Yeah,
the main room.
That's good.
When you,
it's good to kill and end.
Not a six show there last night.
I really,
David tell us the secret gassed.
Oh,
it's hell.
Came by the Ice House last night too.
It's great.
I love that guy asked him.
There's a few people that I see I have
to sit and hang out with is so great.
Yeah.
There's a sweethearts comedy.
Sweet Arts.
Have you seen Nick Nicky glaciers,
new show?
Uh,
it's actually really funny.
I liked it.
Yeah.
She hooked people up to macguires
producing that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Chris Mcguire is producing it.
So funny,
right?
I believe he is.
He was at one point in time,
I'm sure.
I hope he's still with it.
This is hilarious.
He's great.
He's just fucking hilarious writer.
So funny.
She hookup lie detectors to her friends
and then ask them if they wanted to fuck
her and like,
like these are real friends.
And they were like,
oh.
Like you could see they were so nervous.
Well that's normal though.
I share those things where they try to
measure deception.
Most had the shittiest joke,
will it be that?
So that's where Amy Schumer got that
idea.
Oh,
how that was.
I'm glad you let that go.
Glad you lob that out there.
I tried those.
I was tried to watch Conan last night.
I like I,
I haven't seen Conan and over a year and
a half and I was like,
is this show even still on?
You can't find it on Hulu.
You can't find out Netflix.
None of that shit.
So still on tbs?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
No birds there once a month.
Yeah.
What do you mean the reason I watch
coated?
No,
I mean like a lot of people have cut
their cable,
like including myself.
I've had it for two years now.
And you rely on like Hulu and stuff like
that to watch everything.
It's not any of those things.
Oh hmm.
What do you would think they would make
some sort of a deal?
No,
I watched Conan on,
I've seen,
I've never watched Conan like live,
I'll watch it on youtube.
There's a lot of that for sure.
Murders.
Conan.
Conan knows them,
so they like,
they know what to do.
Like he gives birds go bird would just
give these wide paths for Berta ramp.
I love Burp last night,
Burr,
he is one of my favorite new comics that
I just got into within the last couple
of years.
Like I could watch that guy forever.
He's really,
he's one of the best ever right now.
Bill is one of the best ever.
He's,
he's really good.
He's really good.
He's really tucked in common.
He's real original.
It's,
it's really him.
It's very authentic.
And he's saying she's fucking some
controversial shit,
you know,
and he's going out there and uh,
it's interesting,
even as cartoon is awesome because just
hearing him,
dude loves bright,
told him,
Hey,
don't even get me started.
So I go,
so bill and I texted him back and forth
with like,
Hey,
we should hang out.
Not podcast hang out.
It's one of the flaws I think I have is
that I look at everything as work
builders.
Not on a,
no,
no.
If you wanna hang out,
we'll fucking hang out.
I'm not going to podcast.
Sort of.
Great.
So we have a cigar or my place cocktail.
Shoot the shit.
How'd the sunset go out and do it at
work?
So the girls go,
do you want to do so?
I said,
no,
my buddy bills coming in.
We've got to is the day Tom Segura
special comes out.
So I got netflix up.
I go,
as a matter of fact,
Oh this is a cartoon girls,
you're like,
cartoons,
why don't you guys watch this is my
buddy bill.
He's coming over tonight.
Let's take a look at it.
First thing is like these cock sucker
mother fuckers and I looks over and
she's like,
are we allowed to watch us?
And I was like,
fuck it.
Your mom's not here.
Let's watch it.
Watch the pilot,
right.
Leanne comes in and says,
what are you guys?
Watch it and go,
okay.
It's got bad words in it,
but it's not like sexual or anything
until we show in.
Leanne says she sees an article on NPR
that says kids being around cursing is
okay.
It's actually very healthy for them to
hear cursing.
It's when kids don't hear cursing that
they believe the world is different.
They believe the world's fucked up.
So like they live in this bubble and
then they do hear cursing and it fucks
them up and in return and so low.
So yeah.
And so leanne is like,
you know what,
let's watch it.
So we watched an interesting concept but
totally makes sense.
That makes sense.
Did you hear cursing when you're a kid?
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Yeah,
yeah.
And it's,
it's just these new age,
I'm going to say Christian,
I'm,
I believe in God,
but like whatever,
like they hae cursing is not around
children.
We think as a new age Christian thing,
I didn't know one parent when I was a
kid that didn't curse,
didn't drink,
smoke in front of their kids and curse.
But that was my whole life.
But I grew up in the south.
Well it's,
I guess it's trying to preserve the
innocence of the kids.
Is that what,
is that what it is?
I guess it's,
they're just words,
right?
It's just words to be able to say that
right away.
Like,
what did we give a fuck?
Why do we have to behave different than
the kids do?
It teaches them boundaries.
It says this is what dad can do.
You can't do that.
When you become a certain age,
you can earn that and you can do it.
But what,
how,
go ahead.
Yeah,
but what if like a kid says like pussy
hole that you don't want kids sank pussy
holes probably they'd have to live in
your house to your pussy hole like well
that could come up with it on their own.
It's not like puts you holes from a
single origin.
People all over the world said pussy
hole and a hundred fifth and languages.
None of them aware that somebody in
Greece,
it already claimed that nomenclature,
but so we ended up watching it and then
bill came over bills and we were at
episode three.
He's like,
you haven't let them see episode four
yet if you,
I go,
no,
he goes,
got,
don't let them fucking tears.
But what's so crazy,
it's like we're sitting in the kitchen
and my daughter walks in.
She didn't give a shit about celebrity.
That doesn't mean anything,
but she heard bill's voice and went
like,
it was like creepy and I was like,
Yo,
Georgia,
this is the guy you've been listening to
all day.
This the dad from that show,
she was like,
look,
she couldn't wrap her head around the
fact that she was hearing the cartoon
guy's voice.
Wow.
I thought that was cool.
But that show is fa.
F is for family as it and it's so
fucking funny.
It's really good.
I want a cartoon so bad.
It's a low.
Why did you make one?
Yeah,
you can cut stand hopes calling part.
I'm on Speaker Stan.
Hope you're on Rogan's podcast.
You're on speaker
fucking phone vibrating in his pocket.
You know what does it delay Kyla volume.
We'll pause it.
You pause it.
Can we pause the show?
No,
no,
no.
He's talking to stand still.
Stand still.
I texted rogue it a picture of you in
the fun house.
Yeah.
I just got it.
Here it is.
Is this me hammer?
Yeah.
I just texted a picture of us.
Oh Shit.
You in the fun house.
What's going on?
We,
we,
we came in late.
Chad shank said he's been watching it
since the beginning.
He goes,
they mentioned my name.
He can't hear us yet.
Oh,
here.
Here.
Go ahead.
Do you hear us Doug?
It's on speakerphone and he should be
able to hear us using speaker phone.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's watching.
Oh yeah.
Hang on here.
Talk to Joe.
Did you just do it?
Well,
I'm just saying you're the only one who
could talk to him.
Douglas.
We have a,
we have a shitty way of communicating
here.
We've got to figure out a better way to
do this because you could only hear us
when we're like really close to this
phone.
You're not wired into anything so we
have to pass the phone around for you to
hear us.
Unless you're like this speaker from
works pretty well.
I was just trying to fuck with callie.
Forget to turn his phone off.
Done Doug.
No,
nobody ever turns it off.
They turn it over.
We're too addicted to turn it off.
Nobody.
Nobody turned shit off.
It's too,
you never know.
Someone might get in contact with you.
What the fuck is going on in the desert
sun?
Ah,
we,
we did bingos disappearance.
I don't know.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
Gay Too.
At the end of it she calls and uh,
reveals her location.
Whoa.
So got it.
Ain't over there.
Still has to be the,
uh,
what's it gonna be?
Is it going to be him or is it going to
be me?
Whoa.
No gunfight.
Don't do that.
No,
no,
no.
Cool.
So you and the guy.
Um,
so,
so you're hopeful that it's all gonna
work out.
It'll work out one way or the other.
I just hope it works out in my favor.
Well,
we agree.
All right.
We'll go back to your podcast.
We're going to go back to the podcast.
All right brother.
I love you too buddy
guys.
Hey everyone.
Check.
It's does Stan hope.
Don't be scared to tell your friends you
love them.
Everybody.
I'd love you to doug.
When I said goodbye,
I liked,
I'd love you to everybody.
Doug sold his podcasts like and coming
up at the very end,
we find out what Bingo did and where she
is.
You can check it out on itunes podcast.
His podcast is so fucking good.
Did you,
you were the one I would lay in bed one
night on the road and I just was like,
I'll listen to stan hope and Chad and
Chalian and Brian had again,
sounds like fucking nanny mcphee.
Just,
Oh,
I love Brian.
He's a smart dude.
But uh,
but they uh,
I listened one night,
I was like,
I'm just going to go to bed and it's
like dig dug and Bingo breakup episode.
I was like,
oh mom porn.
Make it a pot of tea.
I'll be listening to this all night.
Or,
I mean,
esther q,
Did you know this?
This is 100% sure.
I found this out the other day.
Extra q on the end of every single one
of her podcasts masturbates and just
record herself masturbating while she's
doing our tour dates and stuff like
that.
And it's legit cause you could hear it
like,
oh like,
and stuff like that.
Like it's on my episode that went,
that I was on,
she masturbated,
came
17 times at the end of the podcast.
No joke.
What was,
so while you were podcasting,
when she was playing with know what she
does is like she recorded a podcast and
then after I leave then she masturbates
and goes,
well that was a lot of fun.
And then she comes and she comes really
fast cause she can make her,
comes herself come so it really fast.
If she's a sex addict,
she's a sex addict.
She's a Gesso.
Did you hear him?
So she did it on Opion Jim?
No.
Oh,
it was pretty good.
Huh?
She's like,
yeah,
I can make my coming self coming 20
seconds.
And they're like,
Gee,
you know,
Jim's like,
oh,
I'd like to see that.
So she goes in a little booth.
I think we're mostly,
we're uh,
we're all the producers.
Are you rock is and just masturbates all
Mike just,
and you can share her.
No,
she goes into the box and no one can see
her.
Oh.
And but she did it.
And I had heard about this end of the
podcast.
Good for her.
I had heard about this end of the
podcast before and I had,
I asked her about it.
She told me about it.
She left my house,
she did my podcast the the day she left
my house and I was like,
I'm just going to hear it for myself.
It is.
I mean,
it is legit.
Not only but that,
but is she gets done having an orgasm
and then just says,
okay,
Columbus,
Ohio will be there the 22nd on the 23rd
and it starts again,
and then we'll stop and go,
okay,
you remember how last week I said I lost
my retainer whole.
I found it and this will start again.
Oh my God.
That really is.
It really is just to go get that
subscribed,
but just cut to the very end.
I didn't know about it and then when I
found out it,
I just was like,
Hey,
let's watch porn and podcasts as she can
wipe podcast.
We just watched porn,
but if it didn't work,
she didn't get,
I tried it.
I gotta I gotta get behind Brian's back
on this one.
It's a pretty legit podcasting episodes
at the end of every one.
It's like 20 times.
It's like you're getting tired phrases.
It makes me horny though.
Immediately I told you had to masturbate
and look at Asian chicks.
How many people were jumping off?
Listen to this podcast right now,
this harbor,
definitely.
It does a number right now.
Now you got your,
like as soon as we start talking or you
guys started explaining how she
masturbates that much,
how many dudes with their deck out?
I'll tell you how many people went right
to esther coups coup and the gang and
just went to the go to the Anthony Cumi
one.
Go right to the end.
Last,
last 10 minutes.
I could have mine.
I'm here.
Oh,
go to Brian.
What red band do rude.
How dare you.
And he just never invited me to be on it
and she's just,
she's just always doing that.
It's pretty good.
No,
no.
Joe,
let me pull it up for you,
Joe.
Let me pull it up for you.
It's really funny.
I can't believe that Bert Kreischer is
doing this against my will.
If it was up to me,
I would not listen for,
I find this offensive,
esther Kool and the gang.
It's like the first one on my thing,
the one she does it.
Anthea Cumbia is actually a really good
podcast,
but you just go right to the end,
so it's hard.
I was already listening to,
okay.
Oh God.
All right.
Oh my God,
yes.
Oh,
I'm going to be in Vegas this week.
20th Friday and Saturday at the South
Point Casino.
Oh my God.
And by the way,
she got 12 minutes left to that.
Yeah.
What a good kid it is.
It is.
But the best is when her going up to be
in Vegas.
Good kid.
Oh,
I got that from my friend.
Jimmy didn't tell you we were in high
school.
Quite a good kid.
He'll grow.
Would be like a total pig.
He'd go,
what a good kid
said that
boy said that.
Oh,
that's why.
That's like one of the funniest thing to
say when a girl like does something
incredibly ridiculous over the top like
that.
While I could kid what you've asked her
coo was a good kid.
She is.
What a crazy girl.
She sleeps at.
Uh,
the spas,
like the Korean spas,
like she just goes there and like lays
on the floor all night.
Is that where she lives?
No,
she just,
when she's in town,
which he came to La last week,
it goes to those things.
Pause every shooter.
She's a deep person too.
She's a very smart girl.
Very unusual person.
I could talk to her.
You get a different sort of a
personality,
you know?
But those,
those like spas,
those Korean spas,
that's the one thing that I'm really
worried that we're going to lose in this
sort of homogenization of the world.
Like real ethnic shit.
Like that Korean spa where it's like old
world.
Everybody's taking their clothes off.
You're all going to go through this
crazy spotting or the Russians where
they do the Banya.
You ever seen that shit I've done at
Bro.
Oh,
you have done it?
I've done it.
What is that like?
And then they get,
they go hot and cold.
They go back and forth right old school.
It makes you wonder,
it makes you really like separate what
we called gay as a kid versus what was
gay in the fucking 1930s that looks gay
on paper.
And Dude,
you're naked.
He lays you on a fucking slab.
Like you're at a morgue.
Just starts washing your body.
Takes Birch bees easy,
totally naked.
And he got washes your ball sack.
Never leg up,
leg up on,
leg up.
Hold on,
hold on.
The Guy Washes you,
washes your body,
your asshole.
Uh,
I'm almost certain he got my asshole.
Um,
almost certainly got my asshole.
So with his hands,
gloves?
No,
no.
He's got,
I think he's got a,
he as birch branches or he's got,
um,
Birch Birch.
It's birch leaves.
That's what they beat you with and he's
holding your ass hole up with that and
he literally leg up.
He gets on top of you.
He cracks your back.
Like he,
he,
it's,
it's fully,
there's a place in New York,
man,
if your next time you're in New York
wearing clothes,
he's not,
he's not any had herpes sores on his
mouth.
Oh.
But then he had just immediately was
like,
okay,
get in bath and then you just go get in
like a ice cold bath.
Coldest water I've ever been in.
Hoppin think like prickling on your feet
and then they get out,
they put you in a room that's like,
oh I'm going to ballpark.
And I know this sounds,
make believe,
but like at like 200 degrees,
it was the hottest room I've ever been
in my life.
Oh my God.
Like it's not,
it's not a sauna.
It hurts your eyes and it hurts to
breathe.
You stand there for like five minutes,
then they come out,
they wash u,
they dunk you,
they put you back in and it's all about
cleaning out your impurities.
I gotta be honest with you man.
I walked out of that place.
Feel clean as fuck.
A little violated but clean is fuck.
Wow.
Just oh he was in a towel.
I totally had on was a towel.
Oh well why does it have to be a guy?
Cause cause it's gotta be strong.
Probably there's a player legs up.
What if you're a big giant dude?
I had follow up,
I'll tell you the name of the place.
So if people want to go,
I follow them on twitter.
This is old school Russian.
I know a little Russian.
So I tried to talk to him and I got in
there and there were like,
okay.
And now that we became friends because
of that.
Yeah.
They,
they also like if you,
you would,
you wouldn't want a woman in that
position of washing a man like that.
No,
no.
I and San Diego,
there's this massage parlor where they
cleaned her first and she like was
lifting my legs.
I've completed my asshole jacking me off
it and then we went to check on me all
day.
Yeah.
You see what I'm saying?
Like a girl would kind of be forced into
that sort of an environment if she had a
wash guys,
assholes.
Like there's,
there's gotta be a certain amount of
guys that want more than you did just
wash their dick and watched her asshole.
Yeah.
To keep watching that.
It felt good though.
Having a,
if somebody wash your luck,
you collect,
cause I,
I laid there and she watched me for like
20 minutes and it felt like,
oh my God,
I'm my baby again.
Kind of it,
it was like this weird feeling I hadn't
felt in a while.
What I'm thinking
is that like having the,
the girl removed from the equation,
it takes out the sex aspect of it.
That's why it's okay.
The dude does it because if the sex
aspect of it is there ea like there's
just a certain percentage of guys are
going to try to fuck that girl and so
her jobs like hazardous,
you know what I mean?
Like if you don't want to fuck every
other guy you wash all day and you're
grabbing their legs and washing their
balls and assholes,
how many dudes going to try to fuck you?
It's like,
could you imagine that kind of a work
environment where like you were like,
imagine if your job was being a at the
counter at a chipotle lay and you knew
you were the guy who was says,
what can I get you?
You were the first guy on the whole
chain of command.
I'll have one of them.
Staples.
All right,
dude,
boom.
White Rice or brown rice.
But if you're that guy,
right?
Okay.
Burrito completely lost my train of
thought as soon as it was I saying
before that you were talking about women
watching you balls.
Oh my God.
Forget what I said.
I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you my theory.
This is going to sound racist,
but I'll say it out loud anyway,
I had a massage from a lady in Omaha who
was black and it was the best massage
I've ever got and the reason I thought
was she's not attracted to me at all.
I remember what I was going to say.
She went to Chicago Lane.
You were the first guy on the line,
the first guy on the line,
and you were the one who asks if you
want steak bowl and eight out of 10
people wanting to fuck you.
Wait,
10 people tried to fuck you while you
were at work like you matt.
Can you imagine that kind of pressure of
having a job like that?
If it was a girl who was wash your
asshole and your Dick,
eight out of 10 guys.
So it's a ridiculous job hazard.
Like if you had any other job,
here's a better example.
If you were a guy,
change his tires at the local gas
station.
Yeah.
But everybody kept trying to fuck you.
He'd be like,
Jesus Christ,
I'm tired of working here.
Yeah.
I just,
I just want to change your tire.
That's all I want to do.
Well,
if you have a guy in a loin cloth and
that guy's washing your balls and your
asshole maybe removes any threat of sex,
it is,
it happens quick Russian dude,
you don't get hard.
It happens quickly.
And I just tweeted it out because if you
want to find it,
it's,
it's Russian baths.
New York,
uh,
Chad Shank just retweeted me.
Um,
but it's Russian bads,
New York and,
and why,
and it,
and I'm telling you when I said this and
this is,
I agree 100% what you're saying,
I don't think they're going to disappear
because uh,
in our country we respect,
I'm going to say minorities,
but we respect minorities not wanting to
be apart,
like wanting to have their own thing.
We just don't respect it with white
people.
So,
so for forever we're going to allow
Russians and Koreans and Japanese and
Asians to have their own little secret
separate towns where like you can't do
their shit because we go as America
where we're over sensitive.
We go,
no,
no.
We got that.
If you want to be a part of our clubs,
you can do that.
We don't even give a fuck about your
clubs and cause you never,
no one's ever been,
there's a karaoke spots.
I don't know if you've ever been in
Korea town and are fucking amazing.
You get a private room with private,
like literally your own screen and your
own video where you and a bunch of
families could go in and do your own
Karaoke.
And it's so much fucking fun.
I've done it in Japan and it's,
it's a blast.
But you can't go if you're white in
America.
What they want to Chen man and the,
they again,
they treat you like shit
until you leave.
Ah,
but
in America will,
we're totally gonna allow that.
We're gonna allow that forever.
That would be racist for us not to allow
that for us to say,
how dare you.
You need to let whites and they'll,
they just shut it down.
They'd find another place to do it and
they wouldn't tell us about it.
Hmm.
These,
I'm telling you to say this,
these karaoke,
that wasn't the case.
Like I liked the fact that those places
exist and that it's like their culture,
but why not let other people go visit
your culture?
What is it?
Why Get mad?
Why?
Why want to kick white people out?
Terrorists.
Dare I say it's natural.
Yeah.
Cause,
I mean dare you say,
how dare you.
That's,
I picked that up from you and you say
how to do,
but listen,
think about it.
We didn't want black people to be in our
country clubs or Jews.
Yeah.
I'm not saying me personally,
but I'm saying art my people.
But it was forced on them.
However,
in Korean spas they don't want white
women just walking in and just getting
up and dressed with tattoos.
They'd fucking kick you out.
But a lot of Korean spas that white
women and not with tattoos.
What do Margaret Cho has a whole chunk.
I've heard her talk about it.
No kidding.
Yeah,
it's,
it's shameful.
Hmm.
I know that's the way in Japan nate,
cause they have those like things you
put over your arms.
It wouldn't let me work out at the gym,
see,
unless I had a long sleeve shirts.
Right.
So,
so my point is,
and I'm just,
I'm saying this for conversation's sake,
I'm not saying it as a point of view,
but is it natural?
I mean look at like look at at black
churches,
you walk in as a white guy.
A lot of times everyone's like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
You're going to an all black and you
just go and I just want to praise God
with you guys.
Then they're like,
oh,
okay.
I mean I guess we have to let you in.
We can't kick you out.
So I think what you're saying,
like you go to these Russian bass plays,
you walk in as a white guy,
they literally like not speaking Russian
and they're literally like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
Is that natural?
It exists so often.
It would be a hard argument to say it
isn't natural because there's so many
versions of it.
So many,
yeah.
It's not that it's the right choice or
that it's ultimately the way people are
going to think and behave,
but to have it exist and to have it be
natural.
I mean it's,
it's obviously natural.
It's so common.
It wasn't so common if nationalism and
racism like on that level wasn't so
common.
It's more of a nationalism even than it
is a racism.
Like there's some,
some countries that are like fiercely
loyal to their country.
They don't want anybody else at,
they don't want to deal with.
The Australian was like that for a long
time.
Wasn't really,
Yo,
you see Asians couldn't immigrate.
I only know this,
I wrote a paper written in high school
or college,
but you see Asians,
they would allow Asians in has changed.
I'm not saying Australia is like that
now,
but then the second question is,
okay,
so we've,
we've said that it's,
that it's natural then.
Then what?
What is the difference?
Like I personally don't want those
Russian baths and there's Korean spas.
I don't want anyone to not have their
own shit.
If you want to have it in this country,
you should have it.
I totally agree.
Now there's personally nothing I've ever
grown up with in my life that I have
that he's just white male.
Uh,
you know,
so I don't really,
I've never really had that experience.
Although it was a child.
I would go into the country clubs and
you'd see just old white men playing
thing,
but like,
so I don't think it'll go away.
But then in my question is why do these
liberals take away everything that is,
liberals take away one thing,
but then the stuff like the Korean spa
or the karaoke place or,
or the Russian baths,
why don't they go in and protest them?
Well,
because the idea is that these small
communities,
they retain a bit of their homeland,
a bit of your,
their past and they'd have their culture
in these areas.
And if you are a progressive person,
the idea is that you're supposed to
allow that kind of thinking because it
preserves this unique culture.
I agree kind of delicate and it is
delicate because the kids that are
assimilating into our culture,
the children of their children that are
assembling into the cities,
like if they're like first and second
generation immigrants,
you know,
they eventually become Americanized and
these cool things like the Russian bath
houses or the Korean bath house,
the bond yes' and there's a bunch of
them,
right?
I think a bunch of different like cool
nick too.
People do.
That would be a show.
I'd watch that on Viceland on travel
channel.
It's kind of interesting,
right?
It's interesting to see all the
different ways that people do things and
if we start putting targets and kmarts
all across the world and that becomes
everything in.
We all learn each other's language and
everything slides into one set of rules
for the whole planet.
Like yeah,
probably won't be as fun.
I mean I never really had a culture so
to speak because I was,
we were transplants from the north in
Florida.
So like I,
I never saw there.
And because my parents from New York and
Philly,
like I never felt southern so I never
got attached to the born in Florida.
I was born in Florida,
but I never,
I owed,
my parents were very liberal and so I,
we didn't grow up saying the m word.
We didn't have a rebel flag in front of
our yard.
So I don't have any,
like,
I always feel,
I always say this a lot and never have
any civic pride,
nor do I have any culture other than
like Irish,
you know,
I grew up like Irish was the thing,
right.
So I would never want to lose the
authenticity of Korea town or,
or ha like,
or,
or chinatown or even the exclusiveness,
like going to a Korean restaurant might.
One of my buddies is Roy Choi.
I haven't talked to him forever,
but we used to live next to,
he did a,
he's the chef.
You've had him on the podcast and uh,
we,
he took us,
he did a,
he does the Kogi Taco truck.
He's got him on the podcast.
Yeah.
No,
no.
You did a 100% sure.
Eddie Wong.
Nope.
He came in with Eddie Wong.
But Roy Choi is a very famous chef.
One of the most famous famous chefs in
La Right now on episode was this type in
Roikoi.
Uh,
Joe Rogan.
I'm promise.
She was.
I watched it and I was like,
so he was with Eddie?
Yeah.
No,
nope.
He was,
no,
I'm a hundred percent certain.
Well I fight.
I fight that Google's right.
Nope,
I'm a hundred percent certain.
Eddie Wong came in one time with the guy
that was in that movie.
The interview.
I'm,
I'm going to go to the match on this
one.
I'm looking at it right now.
I just move on today and you're wrong.
So Bert Kreischer is going deep and he's
taking chances.
They're each predictions.
He's challenging young Jamie on the air.
Boy,
I think we got a little too high before
this show.
Rogan honest with you.
We've got a little ridiculous.
Roy Choi.
Did I misspell it?
Roy Choi,
Joe Rogan experience with Brian Stann.
Hmm?
What?
No,
that's definitely not sure.
It says,
it says Roy Choi.
I promise you.
Well Brian,
Stan was definitely by himself because
right?
Yeah.
Can someone please just tweet the
fucking answer to me cause I'm,
I promise you I saw it.
I,
and I would barely should make these
people do the work when you're not doing
this one.
Not too far.
I'm too fucked up to do that.
Okay.
But I promise you it's all in here.
One time.
I know he's wrong,
but I'm like God Damn Z,
right?
Roy Choi,
Bro.
Fucking Jamie.
The,
uh,
Roy Choi created the TACO truck.
K uh,
he's good friends with Anthony Bordain
and uh,
sorry,
maybe you're spelling it wrong.
Racist.
Whoa.
How dare you.
How dare you cast upon him a moniker
that cannot be shaken.
So anyway,
damn,
I don't even know where if I was going
with this point,
have any more wine.
It's getting hot in here.
All sorts of different types of alcohol.
We're probably out of one young Jamie,
Jamie's going to find out,
but I don't know where my point with
this going.
Oh,
he took it.
He took me on my wife to uh,
he took me and my wife to um,
uh,
to Korea town to go eat Korean barbecue
cause you wanted to teach us from real
Korean barbecue.
Like what they,
the kind that we believe it is.
Right.
And it was interesting.
We went in there and no one's spoken,
no one,
there were not only were there any white
people,
no one spoke English at work there.
And so we actually were complete and
total tourists in our own town and just
sat and watched him order and,
and he just was like,
don't worry,
I'll,
and it was really fascinating
experience.
Would I want that place to ever go away?
Never in a million fucking years.
I want those places to last as long as
son of a bitch.
Champagne motherfucker brought out
champagne.
Damn.
Is this cause you're wrong,
Ma Fucka have a birthday.
Uh,
but uh,
but like I believe in that.
I know,
but I,
I,
then again,
we're on the same liberal side of the
fence because I am a,
I've,
maybe I'm a libertarian or whatever.
I am.
I'm a liberal.
I'm a conservative liberal.
You're conservative.
Liberal.
Yeah.
What do you liberal about?
Like gay rights,
gay rights,
all rights,
all human rights,
all female gay rights,
transgender or you name it.
I don't want you to feel like shit.
If I can help that,
that's my job as a comic.
My only goal is to make people laugh.
Oh,
why would I ever want anyone to feel bad
about their day?
That's not my Mo.
Beautiful.
And what do you conservative about?
Um,
like blacks?
No,
no,
the right to tell that to you.
Yes.
That's what I'm conservative about.
Is that conservative anymore?
Yes,
it is.
Because it's still conservative,
conservative value to be able to express
yourself in a way that it'd be
offensive.
Did you see that,
that recent ruling,
young Jamie pulled this up because it's
kind of interesting.
The court ruled against this idea that
uh,
there should be laws against,
what can I calm down is about to release
the crackin.
He's going to open this cork and Brian
is terrified.
Like he's never been to the gun range.
I of those hit me in the eye before.
Oh,
there you are partying with the wrong
people sign.
I want you to mix it into that wine and
make a fine rose a Zinfandel or some
shit.
A wine cooler that's like a watermelon
lime cooler.
Barlow,
James Bartles and jaymes strawberry,
right?
Strawberry
double it up.
Mothers drink during the day,
doesn't take one of the gin.
Hey,
whoa,
listen.
Okay.
I'm Kinda hammered right now where we're
all hammered.
We're all stone too.
He just said you went to take it on the
Chin after giving a story about a man
massaging.
I'm really led down to the Internet,
not backing me up with this roy toy
thing and like starting to date it looks
like,
but I'm pretty sure he's right.
He's not right.
He's right on this all the time.
Is that racist?
It's just a gong.
Can we get away with a gong for anybody
gets mad or that you're thinking of?
No,
it's Roy Choi.
I want to fucking call him.
God,
no,
nothing.
Roy Choi.
Sorry.
I'm looking at all the Eddie Wong
episodes.
He was in here.
He wasn't in here sweetie.
It's okay.
Jamie.
Sorry.
I mean this is the only place I've
worked here.
It was in this building and I pretty
much remember every single one you
would.
It would have to be super old school
like to the point where I don't remember
it anymore.
Last time you were on the show,
we drove home together or the time
before and you talked about your friend,
so it must have been within the last
three months.
Then I only know this cause he's done.
He's done brain tumor or something going
on.
You Tony.
I'm sorry.
I hydrated.
He,
I've done,
he's done bourdain show and he's done
your podcast and he'd do neither for me.
So I remember going like,
like a per day and I get it.
Why wouldn't you go on with the board?
And one of the greatest people on
television for chefs.
But I was like,
podcast was like,
I was like,
and I get why you do joe,
but like throw me a bone,
Roy.
Like we were,
he's a good guy.
He's a great guy.
But his,
uh,
um,
no,
I don't want to get removed from the
podcast.
Eddie Wong and Shane Smith.
I guarantee let's,
maybe you hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Go to the video,
go to the videos and see if there's
another Asian guy.
Was there another Asian guy in here with
them?
Yeah,
one time there was,
it was,
uh,
it was the dude from a,
yeah,
he was from that show,
the show,
uh,
off,
off the book.
What was it?
Off the boat.
Great.
Fresh off the boat.
Okay.
I will spend,
no,
I know what I'm doing tonight.
It's no big deal,
dude.
Um,
he can be wrong.
I think you're right.
Don't attach your whole life to this.
It's just too hard to win at everything
in life.
You got to let some certain losses.
They're going to come your way and
you've got to regroup and you've got to
pick up the paces,
paces,
pick up the pieces and move on with life
for Christ or bigger fan of your
podcast.
And you are of your podcast per person.
I watch all of them.
Cheryl can,
how could you ever say that?
That Joe Rogan's,
he's not saying anything either.
So Yeah,
David Choe found it.
I don't even think anybody named Roy has
been on the pod.
He came on with David Show.
Yup,
he did.
He's right here.
David was been on a few times,
maybe came to one of the ice house
chronicles.
Was it an ice house?
Chronical?
Nope.
I'm going through this.
Was It on David's show?
I did David show once.
That's it.
It was five 92 with David.
She was the one episode I wasn't here.
Oh Shit.
Could have been the one episode,
but Jamie was on five 63 that can't be
that dumb,
dumb,
dumb.
What wasn't gave it shows podcasts that
when did Joe Rogan was on that podcast
could have been.
I think that's makes more sense.
Number five 92 I have horrible
podcasting and know it's done.
I have a hard time believing when we've
actually done 750 podcasts.
I was all five 90 to 769 69 I've done
769 podcasts.
Indeed preposterous.
It's great man.
I like what you did.
Don't know.
I think I may have told you this one
fucked up.
I'm,
I'm very,
uh,
I'm envious in a sense of what you've
done and only,
I only that I could not do it.
Begin it now.
What you did is you kind of took,
you kind of took the renaissance to
yourself and you allowed people that
think differently than you to come to
you and talk to you and you got to kind
of like soak it in their information
like a sponge as a standup man.
That is like,
that's the fucking,
that's what we all should be doing.
Instead of just sitting around and
going,
what does this guy think about
airplanes?
What is it?
You know what I mean?
You really kind of broaden the spectrum
of what you want to talk about on stage.
And I remember hearing Chris rock say
that he got invited to Cornell Wallace's
house for Sunday dinners and right
before he did his most monumental hour
and he was like,
you know,
it was really cool.
I didn't say anything.
I just would sit and listen to all these
great black wallace or West Cornell
West,
my bad.
Hey Bert.
Roy Troy was at an episode of getting
Doug with high with Horatio's stands,
a hero's show and me have often been
confused race.
There's no way.
Yes you are.
Are you serious?
You know it happens.
Let it go.
Just embrace the loss.
Take it on the Chin and move forward.
Soldier on,
sir.
It's no big deal.
Burt wanted a minute.
Look at them.
Very competitive.
It's getting doug with high.
You.
You
realize Doug's competitive.
Robert's competitive.
Not Competitive at all.
The opposite of competitive.
No you're not.
I'll let you walk all over them before I
try to beat you.
No,
no,
no.
100%.
I shot skeet shoot with Bert.
That's very competitive.
Don't let them lie to Ya.
Let he plays pool.
Very competitive.
You're a secretly competitive guy.
You don't want people to know you're
competitive,
cause competitive people are aggressive
and aggressive.
People make people uncomfortable and
uncomfortable.
People are assholes,
right?
Fuck yeah.
So you're saved that file and make it my
ringtone.
Secretly competitive people were openly
competitive,
are also opened a lot of criticism.
So you're seeing really competitive.
Blocked a motherfucker today.
He's really good at a skeet and he's
good at shooting those clay pigeons way
better than me.
Yeah.
He cheats on his fitbit too,
cause he knows that we're,
our accounts are connected.
So he just like sits,
it goes like this real fast steps.
No,
I put on my dog,
put it on your dog's deck and give him a
stuffed animal.
I had a buddy of mine in high school and
he had this fucking dog.
There's the most ornery little dog,
a little poodle,
little type fucking thing.
And this thing would fuck stuffed
animals and it had a stuffed animal that
it was his girlfriend and he would bite
this stuffed animal in the neck and drag
it around and he would just fuck it.
It's weird.
One girl animals still hump because a
buddy of mine,
Joe Spagnolio,
did you know that girl animals still
hump because it's still in their DNA.
It's not.
It has nothing to do about like sex.
What do you mean?
It's like,
it's like a,
it's supposed to be like dominate.
Like I'm dominating this other thing.
It's like a girl will get on top of a
dog and like,
right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
totally man.
They do that to dominate him.
That's fucked up,
right?
Yeah.
They,
they're like,
they mimic fucking to dominate female.
Do that.
It's funny,
my wife withholds it to dominate.
That's what they do.
God dammit part,
it's got damn shell game.
It is with me right now.
You ever see the female Hyenas Dicks?
I hold on.
If you ever seen a hyena up close.
No,
my think,
I don't even think I've seen one at the
zoo.
Maybe I seen a fucking massive,
oh,
they're big animals.
It's like 200 pounds,
right?
It has to be bigger if you,
I psalm one up within five feet of it
and I literally said,
if that thing rolled through your
neighborhood,
you'd think it was a fucking werewolf.
Like one of the most powerful bites all
the mammals to so incredibly powerful
jaws and low hindquarters.
Like almost like a gorilla baird up.
Brian Callen told me his fucking story
once about this,
I guess,
I don't remember it was a guy or a girl,
but uh,
they were a tries of are you getting a
third hand stoned version of this story?
But someone was training hyenas and they
rolled the ankle and had a limp
and as soon as the Hyena realized they
had a limp,
even though the a train this Hyena,
the Hyena attacked him and it took a
chunk out of their calf just clamped
down and a bit them and they had a fight
it off and it couldn't help itself.
It saw her like limping and its
instincts took over.
A just kicked in even though like this
person was trained,
I don't remember what was the guy or
girl if they were training this fucking
Hyena,
like when the shit hit the fan,
when the Hyena saw limp.
It's nature.
It's,
it's like programming kicked in.
That's nuts,
man.
Like the nature nurture argument.
I guess it didn't work on hyenas.
Fuck no man.
These things are monsters.
Monsters.
They're fucking,
they're really weird.
It's a weird animal,
man.
The females are bigger than the males.
I'll give them dude,
come on that sign an avatar animal.
That's a real animal.
That is a total God avatar.
Anna,
living in Africa with lions,
this picture is of,
it might not be a cock.
It might be a female cock.
The babies come out of those things too,
dude.
That's what's crazy.
The babies come out of their dick.
Yup.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I might be so high.
It's so funny looking at it.
Is that like used as the same as a cock
or is it just like a woman?
Like a female has a Pussy Boehner.
Sometimes it comes out like our clit and
gets long and far.
No,
no,
no.
This is,
it's called a foe penis.
I think it's the only mammal that has a
foe.
Penis.
I Dunno if I need reptiles or fish have
one,
but it's a fake penis and that fake
penis is also where the babies come out.
So if it's a female,
a female has sex.
I don't know how the fuck she has.
Can we not see them?
Look at the birth of the baby comes out
of there where there's a man,
male have sex.
Jamie investigate.
Where is the male stick is done.
It's called Jamie.
I know this.
It's called Daca.
Hyena giving birth on Safari.
Jamie go.
Jesus.
What happened?
I missed it.
Just watching.
A lot of baby stuff come out of her
pussy hall puts his Dick.
You can't see pussy if it's an animal
because you look at it just comes out in
the sack.
If you say animals pussy,
you seem like a real creep.
Yeah,
but vagina even sound awesome.
Look at that fucking Oh,
oh good golly.
Walk at that thing.
What a weird animal.
And then what a harsh,
harsh fucking place to live.
Do you see that picture I posted on
instagram meal the day somebody posted
it on the message board?
I uh,
I found it on the Google.
Yeah.
Are Copied and pasted on my own.
Which one it was,
but it's a lion with a um,
whoa.
Is that the female fucking the mail or
mating?
Ooh,
this is an actual meeting.
Meeting Hyenas at the zoo.
Okay.
Oh my God.
So that's where we got it.
Oh God.
What in the fuck.
By the way,
my wife gives that same face sometimes
like wrap it up.
Pig boy,
people are watching.
This is horrific.
Oh my God.
He's calling in.
He's doing yard on that pussy.
But it's almost like he's like barely
alive.
Like he's,
this is like,
he's like,
he's trying to climb a fence and he
can't quite get over it.
You know,
it doesn't look violent.
It looks like he's a dying person trying
to make it over a fence and the noises
he's making.
It sounds like esther co he's checks
after,
after he shoots his load in there and
starts licking her.
Oh,
he cream pied.
He discussing cream pies gusting
perfect.
She's just frozen there.
Look at her.
She's like,
what just happened that you never
happened before?
What just happened?
You gotta think like that's probably the
first time she's ever been fucked,
right?
That Hyena,
that the female,
no,
I'm sure she's been being full line to,
it was a pop.
I promise you that.
I don't meant to sound racist about
hyenas,
but fucking monsters.
But don't they have rules in the
Armenian community and you can fuck your
kids.
They all fuck kids manatees right now.
I'm gonna get hate mail.
If you could,
what would you pick?
Ready?
Uh,
are safari with your children?
Right,
right.
Goes far.
I see all the animals or hunting trip.
Uh,
one of the good ones where it's
conservative and it's the money goes
back to the people.
I don't want to go hunt in Africa.
Really.
I can't imagine any conservation
argument that you could ever make,
which is like one of the most important
arguments for,
for hunting.
I don't,
I can't imagine any conservation effort
you,
you would make where it's like to get
your meat,
you're going to get in a plane and
you're going to fly across the ocean.
It's going to take you 16 hours and then
you're going to kill something over
there and they get it.
Bring it back on a plane all the way to
California or the way to Michigan or
wherever you live.
Like
the only reason why I'd be going over
there is cause I enjoyed hunting and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that,
but I haven't crossed into that yet.
I'm not into it and I shouldn't even say
yet because I don't think I ever will.
I'm never going to shoot a lion.
I don't want to shoot anything I don't
want to eat.
I don't want to go.
I just don't,
I don't have a desire to like go and
shoot something that I would never bring
home and eat.
Like those,
those things are sort of,
they don't make any sense to me.
I get the,
I get how they need to happen.
Like you know the Zimbabwe,
this is an article recently about the
Cecil,
the lion thing that's kind of fucked up.
They're going to call 200 lions in
Zimbabwe because hunters aren't going
there anymore.
So they have this too.
They have too many lions.
So because they have too many lines,
the cows,
the angeles,
the wild animals that they have roaming
around through the,
the fields,
apparently they're getting devastated.
So their solution is to go out and call
200 lines,
which means they're going to shoot him.
Not only is it not going to give them
any money,
but they're going to have to pay money
to someone to go out there and find
these lines and shoot them.
So it comes at a desk.
A deficit
is Zimbabwe Park to call 200 lines site
lack of hunters.
So since there's the look,
it's not,
see,
again,
I'm not saying that you should go on a
lion.
I would never,
I have no interest in killing a lion,
ever.
No interest.
However,
however,
how much,
so like let's ballpark it.
$50,000
for each line.
So if they're going to do 200 lines,
it'd be what does that $10 million and
this is hurting my,
the lines.
No,
it's not that much.
$10 million.
It's a million,
right?
At $2 million to dollars.
Wait a minute.
How many people is it?
How many?
It was $50,000
and how many lions?
200 so it's,
it's $200 thousand lines.
And it was,
it was a hundred hunters.
It would be our hundred thousand dollars
and $50 it's two.
It's 210 months.
It was Roy Choi is $10 million.
It's 200 lines at $50,000
a lion.
Right?
So they missed out on all that money and
$10 million that could keep the pride
health.
How is it $10 million?
Because if it's $100,000
and there's a hundred lions,
isn't that now $100,000?
Yeah,
it's 10 million bucks.
Welcome.
I hope they're drinking partying with
us.
Oh,
for sure.
People are,
I just think like be the dumbest person
at math ever lived.
It's like sport.
The top,
I'm in the top three doubles people at
math.
Yeah,
sports and math.
I just had a visual.
There's two.
This should be a sketch.
Joe with his daughter doing math and her
going like,
I don't fucking know her.
Just him just stopping to go,
want to learn the number.
This is what I,
this is what I learned when I was in
high school calculators.
They're always right and we're not going
to run out of batteries.
So what you'd do is you'd go to a
calculator and in my fucking brain I was
done.
Two numbers were not even remotely
important to me.
I don't the,
the quest for like to,
to calculate things and I get that.
It's a nice little game.
It's a little puzzle for your mind,
but it's not interesting enough for you.
Do you remember when they told you,
oh,
and you'll just carry a calculator in
your pocket around all day or are you
going to learn how to do math and you're
like,
how can we calculate a stupid,
how often does it come up?
I mean I knew how to like carry the
money.
If I,
if I worked at a register,
someone maybe a $27 and 50 cents due
back and change and knew how to dish
that I was fucked that one up.
I would always go see,
gave me 20 bucks.
You paid $16 well here's four and then
here's the change.
I was given a dollar extra.
I never did the math of like three and
then or whatever.
It's so funny mathematics or weird thing
because
it's a simple mathematics like
calculations like addition,
multiplication,
division stuff.
Do you have to do in your head that that
everybody associates with math like Oh
God,
that's so boring.
But then you get to weird math like
math.
That's kind of solving equations about
like how big a black hole is trying to
figure out like gravity waves and
they're doing a lot of that stuff with
mathematics and they're analyzing data
and measuring and calculating and trying
to figure out like the way the fucking
universe works.
And it's all with some strange math that
you gotta go deep,
deep,
deep into get to that goodwill hunting
shit.
They,
when they,
oh someone make one video of just
explaining that kind of problem.
And what's the deal with remainders?
I don't understand.
I don't know.
Is saying clown possie right now.
And what's the deal with the remainder
magnets
by the way,
in a parallel universe,
everyone's drinking it.
Doug Stan hope's house watching this.
What a great fucking life.
This is hilarious dude.
Fucking magnets.
How they work,
Bro.
I got a credit Brian Poo sane for
fucking in turning me on to that.
He said that somewhere and I heard him
say that and I fucking left dude.
You gotta say two days.
Steve Agee is one of the funniest
motherfuckers alive.
That guy's so fucking talented.
Next thing.
Mct Oil.
In your shakes.
Don't put a lot or you poop your shelf.
It's true and strong,
strong advice.
I deserts,
I'm put a teaspoon in a couple of
tablespoons,
you'd be fine.
Does it fine.
Do you find that it binds to you longer
and you binds to you?
So I do my shakes,
my shakes,
our uh,
our um,
k like a little Dick Loaded Kale,
a alma milk your protein and you pack
your Dick with a stick or when you get a
dick load usually happening around the
outside with baby powder load.
I feel it all the way to the top of
Kale.
Right?
And then I pushed it down a little bit.
I put some frozen fruit and they're
usually blueberries or something.
I do your uh,
hemp protein.
And then I do mean green from trader
Joe's and that's my shake.
Okay.
But then I just heard you say somewhere
that mct oil helps bind the proteins
are,
helps bond the nutrients to your,
to your fat cells.
And I believe Rob Wolf to told me that,
who the fuck told me that one of those
guys.
So I was doing my shakes and I was
noticing shitting like a wolf within two
hours before,
before the MCT oil.
I take the mic,
oh shit.
Fucking right out of his ass.
Crazy like Howell's.
Why does it,
yeah,
it's going to be quicker than a dog than
a house dog.
How many anger involved?
Oh Dude,
it's a wolf.
He's got predators.
He's got of pack.
He's got to hang with it.
Fucking happens quick.
Why are you using Kale and mean?
Green is they're not the same shit.
I don't know.
I would imagine on wolf would take an
angry shit.
Teeth glared just just shitting out
quick because it doesn't want to feel
vulnerable,
doesn't want some other wall to come
along and try to take the office spot.
I agree.
What a Rudel society can imagine.
If you were a wolf and you just lived on
a mountain and all you did is run around
and bite shit chase things and you're
your number one instinct is chase things
and chop at their legs.
That's what they like to do.
I'd like to run up behind cows,
run up behind elk,
whatever.
You can get deer and they paint their
legs,
their legs,
and they,
they'll chase them and they bite their
legs again and they'll take down a big
ass animal.
That way they'll take down a mousse.
Sounds like social justice warriors.
Fuck yes.
Are you upset?
It was social justice warriors?
Yeah,
hundred percent.
What's going on?
Oh,
like when I see someone like Kurt
Metzger who I find to be fucking
hilarious,
when I watched people attack him based
on,
based on some list of fucking demands,
they have like terrorists as opposed to
the demands.
What did they do this,
this,
this is a broad stroke.
I know that Kurt almost lost his job on
amy show by amy saved him.
Amy stood up for him,
but because he did some thing,
I'm,
Kurt didn't want to talk about it,
so I'm not gonna talk about it,
but okay.
I mean,
maybe he did talk about it.
You Go,
I'm sure curse on the show.
Jamie mother fucker.
But uh,
but like,
I don't know man.
I just find,
I just find that shit bothersome and I,
and I,
it looks like wolves just trying to bite
until someone goes,
until some corporation goes,
he's been bitten the doll,
it's fucking weak.
Let's eat it.
This is what I think we have to really
be
careful about.
We have to really be careful about an I,
I mean us,
I mean as humans we got to really be
careful about trying to get other people
to think and behave the way we do.
Like once you establish like sort of a,
uh,
a guideline of how we all want to be
treated with each other,
you're going to have disagreements.
And if you believe one thing and I
believe something that's different than
what you believe,
it can become a real problem if I
decided to go after you for your belief
and attack you for your belief and try
to get you fired for your belief.
Right?
Yeah.
That's where it gets weird.
Like,
and especially when it comes to
something like standup,
which requires a certain amount of
offensive thinking they requires,
if you want stand up that I'm going to
enjoy.
You got to take some risks,
you got to be offensive.
You,
you have to be offensive and an honest
way that is undeniable,
especially in this era because we're
living in this era where we're supposed
to pretend that certain differences
don't exist and diversities the most
important thing.
But there's some hilarious differences
and it's one of the reasons why we like
black comics because black comics can
shit all over white people and it's just
the same kind of funny racial
humor and it's totally acceptable
because white people been Dick's to
black people for so long that it's like
in,
it's just in the guidelines.
It's a lot.
It's like if you go back to old like
Eddie Murphy or Richard Pryor bits,
like they were great and white people
like them,
you know?
It's like,
like it relieved a little tension to
have him shit on white people,
you know?
Yeah.
I like Katt Williams.
I still like Katt Williams.
Yeah,
dude,
I want to tour with their guys.
That guy is so the one I love when he
gets into a preachy mode,
do I like what he's sweating in?
His hair's fucked up and his shirts
soaking.
I love that dude.
He's wild and you know he gets crazy
sometimes and things go off the rails
yesterday.
He's awesome.
Did he go off the rails yesterday?
Something like that.
He punched some guy.
Maybe that guy was talking shit.
Okay,
I got your back cat.
I got,
I'm on cats team right now.
Funny as fuck man.
I think he's one of my all time favorite
comedians as far as like,
like when he's in the groove,
when he's talked and moving and he's
crushing it.
He's a motherfucker,
dude.
He's maybe your ass pussy.
I liked dude.
Katt Williams is fo force in nature when
he's on.
He's a force of nature,
man.
He's just so good.
The thing is,
Shit.
Oh,
Challenges Kevin Hart to a $5 million
battle and explains Georgia arrest.
How do you not love this?
Oh my God,
I love him.
Well,
social media,
boy,
I know what you do,
but you do it from life.
Life.
Have you do it for real.
Here it is,
Kevin.
I've got a show at Joe Hometown and
Philly.
I'm gonna tape my special Nair on that
stage.
We can put whatever you want.
A full court basketball court,
a boxing ring,
two microphones for a rap cypher,
or you can get y'all ass dusted in
comedy on that stage.
$1 million up for each one.
That's $5 million minster 28 million in
forms.
I'll be bringing mine and cash.
Mitch,
bring yours however you won't as issue.
Not a puppet.
Don't bring no white people with in.
You didn't take it all or you had taking
part in parcel.
Oh my goodness.
The no load by the way,
he's wearing a fur coat.
Oh,
He made try.
It's hard over his face.
He made a hard side stand in front of a
Lamborghini.
Just got out of a private jet.
We make enough money to drink out a real
blast where?
Oh Shit.
Do you get that reference?
Told them to give her the plastic cup.
No.
Okay.
I love Kevin by the way.
Love cat.
Okay.
Kevin did a comedy group with all the
guys at tour with them and they all,
the guys that tore them,
they call themselves a plastic cup boys.
So he goes to,
so he says,
fuck y'all plastic cup boys.
We drink out of a real glass.
Oh,
I want
to be black right now.
So fucking bad.
Can you just enjoy on the sidelines
without wanting to be a part of the
actual,
I want to.
I want it.
You know what I want to do?
I want to tell me I want,
I want to be in that world.
I want to be in a fur coat.
I'm going to recreate that with,
but I'm going to do it to Thompson Mura
and and I'm going to be like,
fuck,
fuck y'all babies.
We got real kids have like you could
reenact it.
Sort of like how they reenact the civil
war.
You guys can read it and ask the cat and
Kevin Hart comedy feud if it were to
really go down.
He's got his jet going in the background
and he got into a Lamborghini dude.
First of all,
who's Lamborghini is that in his jet and
where'd you get the fur coat?
And he's only bringing in $5 million of
his cash.
He does not have enough done.
Well,
he might,
he might.
I mean,
look,
that guy can do giant places.
Katt Williams.
Even though,
like I said,
he's gone off the rails a couple of
times.
He could still do giant player.
He's one of the best comics in the
world.
Why?
Why has he not been on your podcast yet?
I never met him.
Oh Dude.
No where we work.
He rolls with shook too.
I've met him twice.
He's a,
he,
by the way,
he's a legit hip hop dude.
He rolled,
I think he went up against Camron and
dip squad and like how to fuck a rap
battle against like,
like,
like uh,
I think someone got shot for it.
Can you google that?
Jamie sequoia was there like,
he's man,
he's a fascinating guy.
When his standup is on,
it's just a sensational and who would,
he's sweating and pacing and you know,
he's just sensational.
What my thing was is that I worked with
my good friends with red grant,
which is one of his openers.
And uh,
he always paid the comics he worked
with,
well,
it was treated them nice.
That's so fucking important.
He,
he said something that I remember
reading or watching a video rather and
he was talking and it made total sense
and I didn't really consider it that
much before.
He was like,
I never eat before I go onstage.
I don't want to have any food digesting
in my stomach.
And then I thought about it,
I was like,
what?
Well,
what is it like the like it could be
like seven o'clock and the show's at
eight like I got to eat.
I gotta.
Yeah,
I gotta eat.
Do you really like most of the time you
don't like,
we're so spoiled.
Like most of the time you can go like a
long time without actually eating and
you'll be fine.
It's like you have a little bit of a
craving,
but it's almost too much for us to lock.
Got Actors on stage and he was saying
that like eating before you go onstage.
It slows you down,
it slows down your thinking because you
body needs the energy to digest that
food.
I'm like,
of course it does.
Of course it does.
And I remember that this is several
years ago.
I remember as soon as I,
I uh,
saw that video,
I was like,
that is how I'm going to think about
that from now on.
Because before I was just thinking about
the moment itself when like I could do
it even though I just ate.
I could be fine and you can if you don't
eat too much,
but eating right before you go onstage
is probably about it.
Yeah.
Those are,
uh,
when I used to work with Jay Moore,
that was a buddy hackett quote.
What's us?
Jamie Katt Williams talk signing with
camera on camera.
On.
Yeah.
He worked with deb squad dipset tip set.
You can't say dip squad.
Dude was that ready?
This dipset dipset are racist.
You know what people love to do?
They love to call you a racist.
So it takes any fucking focus off of
their potential racism.
That's a big one.
I definitely couldn't be a racist.
But what you are did dip,
dip squad,
stip set.
You don't even know what it's sad is he
shouldn't be commenting on their
culture.
There's a very big difference from being
called racist and doing something racist
on accident.
Oh yeah.
The both.
Both are possible.
Like I did,
I did something.
No,
but I mean like meaning like I've been
called like I've been,
I've had,
I've had whatever person go,
oh,
that jokes racist and you're like,
it's not racist at all at all.
There's no racism in that joke.
Um,
but,
and then I've done something racist on
accident and then realizing you've done
something that is in fact hurtful is
like,
holy fuck,
you're,
you're almost taking the real meaning of
the word away from the word.
Uh,
it,
does that make sense?
Well,
it's,
you can't change the definition.
So what race has immense,
no.
Well,
yeah,
but I think people lighten the load.
Like I though,
I'll tell you the two examples.
I used to have a joke.
There's Hackey I'm gonna just say it
real quick.
Or you say you want to know something
racist.
That was where my flaw,
because people would hear that and
assume I was about to say something
racist.
Right.
When in fact I'm about to say a joke and
it was,
they don't make baby powder for black
people.
Like how racist is that?
They should make eight different colors.
Call it magic Johnson and Johnson's
stupid joke.
Black woman got upset,
stormed out of the date and funny bone.
Literally,
I'm going to protest now.
I did something racist one time where I
walked into a,
but I didn't mean to do it.
I was,
I'm a big fan of opiate anthony.
I think this will attest to anyone
that's listened to opiate anthony.
And uh,
one of the sayings they used to say on
that was,
hello boys.
Like it was like a saying from the show.
Uh,
and I rolled into a all black club in
the eighth,
I think the eighth ward,
it's called bullets.
And I walked into the bathroom was all
black men and I was a little buzz.
Oh Geez.
And I just wrote it was,
but it was all old black men.
It was all old black man.
Oh No,
I know.
And I just walked in one hello boys.
But now you gotta understand my,
my,
my usage of that is based on Opie and
Anthony,
which was just to show that they had
that line in their opening trailer.
Yeah.
And so I wasn't,
I definitely didn't,
I would never my ever in a million years
ever do something like that.
However black man grabbed me and pulled
me aside.
So you don't say that word in here.
And I realized I did something racist
and I went that,
that feeling,
that heartfelt feeling I had where I
went,
I am like literally almost in tears.
Like I am so sorry.
I have no idea what that brings up in
you.
And I didn't know that,
but I had no intention.
And that is the two differences where I
go,
don't don't throw that word around
unless you're,
unless you're ready to throw the glass.
The Rock in the glass house,
that's a word you could easily throw
around in a room full of white guys and
you were thinking in a non racist way.
Just let it out.
You let it out because you would let it
out all the time.
But it's,
it's a perfect way to describe it.
It's accidental racism.
100% I think we've got a real problem
with people looking for stuff that's
racist.
It isn't though.
You know like tea,
like a thing like that.
You would have to find out who you are.
Like who is this guy?
Why is Bert Kreischer Guy?
You know?
It's like has he done stuff?
Is this funny for him?
Does he think it's a boundary pusher
guy?
We want to go into a room full of black
people in say some racist is just like,
like Ari when he was doing the amazing
racist.
Remember that
dude?
That's the reason I know Ari is so
crazy.
That's the reason I know Ari.
That is,
that's a sketch.
You know that and I look and I've showed
it to people since maybe times have
changed from when I first saw that to
went now when I saw the one Negro one.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm not telling you.
I'll tell you what.
It was like 2004 I just had a kid and I
was sitting up in my house,
my house having a bottle of Jameson.
I was working with Jameson at the time
and I saw it and I had seen already
before and I giggled.
Hardest fought.
I'm going to own that.
That there was a time where that was
funny.
If it's not funny now and people hate
it,
I giggled hardest.
Fuck.
It's still kind of funny.
I mean it's fucked up.
It's definitely fucked up,
but it's still kind of funny.
What's more fucked up as the guy from
fucking sham wow.
Owns all that shit that is kind of
fucked.
That's the most fucked up about all of
that is sham.
Wow owns all of that.
How much,
what do you think he's making Jamie?
Like 80 grand a month on those.
See like your situation,
like if they knew you like anybody else
knows you,
then there would be no worry.
It would be just,
I got drunk and I fucked up and I said
the wrong thing.
I said the actual,
I just said the wrong words.
Isn't it interesting that that thing
where you did that,
if they did know you and they knew you
said the wrong words and you knew they
knew that,
okay,
this guy genuinely would have said this
to a bunch of white people and he just
slip of the tongue and it just was,
listen,
Ben Opie and Anthony and it was in my
fucking repertoire of words to say when
I walk in a room.
But there's a giant difference between
that and someone who walks in that
bathroom with a decided intention to
make those black men uncomfortable.
There's sharks in there.
Yeah.
And he says difference.
However,
however,
there's no distinction between what we
did to them.
Especially if they're like you.
They've had a couple of drinks.
Yeah.
Like you,
you were all at a bar.
Right?
So maybe they could be a little tipsy
too.
And you know,
sometimes people are a little drunk and
they misinterpret things where they're
quick to a,
to quick to look for an altercation.
That could be a problem too.
You know,
name of the bar was bullets.
I was there to see kermit ruffins.
I was hanging out with him and his car
and uh,
nothing.
I'm just thinking,
oh,
go ahead.
And,
and I,
and I and I,
when I bought that,
that is in essence,
like I remember,
I remember just the
guy pulling me aside and literally
grabbing me,
not,
not be a nice about it,
but grabbing me so you don't say those
words here.
And I went,
whoa.
Like I didn't grow up racist.
So I don't like to say,
boy,
what's a trunk mistake?
Yeah.
I did drop any
exact thing when I moved here.
It's like the first six months I was at
the comedy store,
I came up to a guy that I knew and I go,
hey boy.
And he goes,
what the fuck she is?
I had no idea.
I'd never heard of the boy thing ever.
And I don't know where he got it from.
Boy in Ohio.
No,
I don't.
And I just didn't have racism in my
family or anything really.
So I never read them was raised as some
sort of a preserve religion.
It's amazing that the fence was up and
there was like,
it was like that.
Remember that?
Uh,
that was it.
Joaquin Phoenix that had that fucking,
that the m nine Shama Lama Ding Dong
movie about those people don't want the
village,
the village.
And there was planes that were flying
overhead.
They didn't know about the planes.
Remember that.
It's one of those movies where you at
the end of the movie like,
I'm going to find him and I'm going to
fucking choke him.
I'm going to find you and I'm going to
choke you.
No,
no,
no.
That is not a movie idea to do that son
of a bitch who let you do this,
who let you spend so much money on this.
You fucker New Hampshire.
I think what?
No planes fly over them.
Get the fight.
I've ever seen a plane the fuck out of
here.
They just made it to the road in a day.
They walked to the road in a day.
It's some fucking hippies aren't going
to find you decades ago.
Shut your mouth.
It's one day and one day they're on the
road the same day.
That's not far.
How fast are you walk in there in the
Cherokee within 24 hours.
So you're telling me you didn't even
hear harleys when Harley's ride down the
road do you didn't hear that the fuck
out of here?
This whole face.
That's sort of what my compound to be
like.
Standups,
compounds.
Just like that guy knocked it out of the
park with his first movie though the
sixth sense,
which was another like twist.
I think those two,
the twist was so good at that movie.
It might've ruined him.
Ariana are talking about storytelling
like that.
The best stories you ever list to,
when did you realize he was dead?
Oh,
spoiler alert.
you son of a bitch.
I never figured it out until now.
What do you mean he was dead?
The kid was dead.
No.
Oh my God.
The guy was dead.
Who is?
Wait.
When did you,
when did you figure it out?
He said it like when the kid and him
were having the conversation towards the
end of the movie.
I was getting suspicious somewhere in
there.
I was like,
what the fuck is going on?
This is like 2004 when did that movie
come out?
Oh No,
it was not 2004 was probably in 1998.
[inaudible] 99.
Wow.
Was it?
Bam.
Roy Choi was on this show.
Careful.
So,
uh,
but I don't remember.
I think it was towards the end.
I think they were having a conversation
together and I was,
but I was trying to figure out what
the fuck was going on before that.
But I can tell you in the moment,
part of the moment of the movie when he
finds blood on his shirt,
oh,
that's what I realized because I was
like,
when he grabbed the red door handle,
I was like,
yeah,
I don't know what that fucking means.
Why did she lock him out of that room?
Is he not have an office anymore?
So he need to get an office.
That was a great movie,
man.
But then the twist was so,
so much of a part of the movie that the,
in his movies you would wait for the
twist.
You know,
he tried to figure out when is this
twist coming?
What's better?
That or usual suspects.
Okay.
I think usual suspects is the goddamn
classic.
It's best.
That's a classic.
What do you mean?
What's,
which one's better to six sense or the
single slit in the reveal though the two
best reveals in movie probably,
right.
Oh,
in the reveal.
I thought you mentioned it in the movie
itself.
In the,
in the butt.
But then the real voc cents is better.
No,
the movie is the reveal.
The keyser soze a reveal is like a
little,
like what?
All of a sudden he's on limping.
Okay.
What about in the final reveal?
It's walks away.
That was the worst.
So it was worst.
I di,
I mean,
I did not like,
and people get mad at me for saying
that.
You don't even understand fight club,
bro.
You don't understand.
You understand what it stands for.
Okay.
Yeah.
What about memento?
Uh,
it was good.
I'll tell you what butterfly effects
probably the movie that butterfly.
Oh,
Ashton Kutcher.
Did you actually watch that?
Uh,
due to kind of fucked me up for a couple
of days.
The pants on.
Why did you,
why did you watch that movie?
Who says what time travel you are Joe?
Like whoa.
Like if you ever have a time travel
person in here,
I just want to hang out and just listen.
I'm,
I'm obsessed with time travel.
Is there a time traveler person?
It's like the big foot guide I think.
Does it offset well there was this one.
Hi.
I think it was the universe.
University of Connecticut Raw Roy Mallet
bottom Ronald [inaudible].
Ronald Mallet.
Yeah,
He was a scientist out of the University
of Connecticut and this is a crazy like
spiderman story.
His Dad died when he was young and he
became obsessed with figuring out Ronald
Mallet.
Uh,
he became obsessed with figuring out a
time machine so he could go back in time
and save his father and flaps.
That's what led him on this path to
become like the world specialist in,
I mean he's like a legit credentialed,
you know,
respected intellectual and scientist and
his,
his accomplishments.
He's like,
he's been able to like try to keep track
of and study time in a way that they're,
they're really thinking that there's
going to come one point in time,
some day,
whether they're going to be able to
figure out how to travel back and forth
through time.
It's going to take a long ass time.
But one thing that he along as time,
one thing that he learned was that he
most likely will never be able to go
back in time and save his dad.
And so the,
the,
I think the idea as it's been explained,
if I remember correctly,
is that you only can time travel back to
the point where the first time machine
was made.
So if someone one day fuck comes up with
a time machine,
say if that's like a hundred years from
now,
the from that moment on from the moment
of the invention of the time machine to,
to forever in the future,
all those people can come back to that
moment.
So you're telling me the first guy that
invents at time of trig can travel back
a second then two seconds than five
seconds.
Mm even know even crazier when the
moment of first time machine is
invented.
All the people that have gone from,
you know,
let's say a time machine gets invented
in 2050 okay.
All the people from 2052 as long as
human life survives and as long as
there's a power source and as long as
there's a computer grid,
as long as there's some method of
establishing information,
all those people will be able to come
back to that moment and any other moment
in between.
So time stops,
there's no regular time.
They might be regular time for you,
but he becomes,
it's,
it's only a matter of perspective
because regular time for you is not
going to matter anymore because people
can come and go back to your time.
How are we sure I hadn't said this as
much as they want.
But then here's another problem.
Here's another problem.
How much mass is contained in this one
environment and is it okay to bring in
more mass?
And what happens if you do?
So if you have,
if you have 300 million people in
America right now,
but a time machine gets invented and,
and then all of a sudden people from
2050 to 250,050
to whenever the fuck the next big
asteroid wipes us out like the
dinosaurs.
You've got super,
super far distance in the future people
every day,
every person has the possibility and
potential with technology to reach this
moment right now.
And what if they did all together all at
once?
What we even have the space to contain
them.
Would we even have the space on this
earth to what we would have to regulate
time travel at every second of every day
from today on until the moment there's
no,
I can debunk this.
Are you ready for me to debunk a
scientist?
Hoping you can do it.
Here we go.
Mic drop moment.
Dear scientists have spent your whole
life figuring this out.
I just shut you down.
So I built a time travel.
Me and Brian are time.
Travel consists of a bottle of
champagne,
a lighter and a joint.
Right?
I'm just saying it's simple,
simpler time machine stopped.
No mental illness.
Can I handle this one on my own?
So I'm just saying simple mechanics.
Let's pretend that that's the time
machine,
right?
So we got it.
All right.
We invent the time machine.
God,
Oh my God,
we right now we can travel back to that
moment three days ago.
We can try to travel back to this moment
or three days and now I can say to
Brian,
hey,
our time machine really just consists of
a bottle of champagne,
a joint and lighter.
Go to f,
let's fucking send you back.
You know the three things,
bill one then come back to me now your
idea,
she gets together with my chipolte lay
person and have sex and have a baby.
That makes no sense you guys.
There's no time machine ever going to be
built because [inaudible] bro,
it's up.
Donald Trump is president.
Cats and dogs living together.
Simulation program,
tie machine,
doesn't matter.
Births,
ideas back to the future three
basically.
Is that what it is?
Jamie?
Jamie shutting your shit down.
I'm interrupting your kettle bell
workout on.
Stop shutting down.
Oh fuck.
Would you like,
we're going to be cool to see like
scientists actually work on time travel.
Like if they're like,
like shooting lasers does that walls and
trying to run through a wall or
essentially
definitely doing it in one way or
another.
They might even not even realize they're
doing it,
but every intensive scientific
experiment that anyone's doing anywhere
in the world,
I need results that they get in
groundbreaking results.
Auger kind of added together and to this
super possibilities.
So whatever they invent today,
whatever they figure out today.
Even if they're not thinking like,
hey,
we're gonna invent a time machine,
but any new technology that someone
invents a day makes more things
possible.
There's more things become possible.
Eventually people are going to get to
the point where they go,
hey,
this time thing,
we manipulate this or is this just what
it is?
Is it what it is?
Or we can we move around in it like the
air.
Remember when we didn't used to think we
could fly through the air,
but then we realized we could fly
through the air.
Why can't we fly through time?
Are you sure we can't fly through time
today?
And if people keep getting smarter and
smarter and more and more aware of the
possibilities that had been created by
all these different technologies,
it's going to open up the door to insane
possibility,
like unimaginable possibility of the
ability to manipulate matter,
human bodies,
time travel.
It's just a matter of whether or not
we'll have enough power and whether or
not we'll,
like if we do it correctly,
we're figuring it out to the point where
like,
we definitely didn't figure out the
fossil fuel thing or the plastic thing
correctly.
We invented it without considering the
consequences of way more fucking people
and way more impact on the environment
than anybody ever imagined when they
first invented those things.
So when you see the oceans choking up
with plastic and the fucking skies all
fucking black with smog from shitty car,
like nobody,
nobody saw that coming when they
invented those things.
So there's gotta be a way where they can
look at all the different things that
we're doing right now and extrapolate
into the future and figure out how to
fix it.
Once they can do that,
then it becomes a matter of how much
energy do you put forth and what are the
rewards that you get back and can,
you can continue to sustain that energy.
So if you can continue to sustain the
energy and you start just creating time
machines and you start creating,
uh,
the ability to manipulate bodies and
change shapes,
you would turn your body into whatever
the fuck you wanted it to be.
And there would be no standard human
being.
There'd be people with fucking wings.
There would be people with giant heads.
You could literally,
if they start manipulating bodies,
it's just a matter of time before they
manipulate them at will and before they
manipulate them back and forth.
What's going to be the first person that
decides to become a horse person and
then besides become a center and then
decides to become the hulk and then
becomes a brony.
You know how many,
how many fucking people are going to do
weird shit to their body once they
realize that you can change it,
you can decide,
you can introduce a gene that makes your
shoulders stretch out wide like this,
give me tomorrow.
You never fucking know.
Give me wings tomorrow,
Dude.
If they can figure out how to splice
genes into different plants to create
like more resistant plants to pesticides
and they can figure out how to
manipulate things.
They figured out how to grow a human
ear,
uh,
on a,
on some sort of a mammoth.
He was a mouse or something like that.
Like they're,
they're constantly trying to figure out
new ways to combine things and
manipulate things.
Just keep going from today to a hundred
thousand years from now.
It's inevitable.
Inevitable,
dude,
they habitable.
Imagine if they had told your
grandparents,
you'll be able to speak to your child on
the other side of the coast.
How would I do that?
It's just look at this human ear.
They grew on a fucking rat,
had kind of looked like Richard Ross
here,
Asian guy.
It looks like,
well,
lead Ishmael's ear,
the UFC fighter.
What's that?
They grew his nose jacked.
Yeah.
They grew his nose on his forehead and
then they cut you open and stitch it
back in.
I was on the forehead or on your face.
What they do is they kind of stretch it
out.
They stretch your skin out by putting
this sort of a artificial nose thing
that they kind of grow on your head.
There's a bunch of different experiments
that people are doing right now.
This is the hope and this is
interesting,
but it's kind of like almost like,
um,
be beginner steps to what they're
ultimately going to be able to do.
No way does this,
are they doing this because there's no
like those plastic surgery stuff?
No,
no,
no.
I got his nose fucked up.
No,
but I mean like meaning you know,
like all of a sudden we have,
we have a cure to fix.
I knows it's gone.
Right,
right.
As opposed to AIDS.
Medication is still kind of like,
they're just like,
we're going to hold it off.
We're not curing it cause the money's in
the comeback.
Do you think that's real?
That's Chris Rock said to Joe,
I don't get all my information from,
I get it from podcasts and comedy and
TV.
You never know.
It definitely could be real,
but I would imagine it would be really
hard for people to ethically hide the a
cure for aids because they can make
money from the treatment.
You'd have to assume that the same
people too.
You'd have to assume that the people
that are making the treatment got ahold
of the cure and decided to stop it.
Either they bought them out or it was
their company that invented it.
You'd have to,
they'd have to all be conveniently
connected.
I guess you're right.
And then there's also a scientist as a
scientist that would have to be involved
in the discovery of something as
monumental as curing aids.
If a scientist could figure that out,
that would be gigantic for the
reputation it would see.
They would be like Francis Crick.
They would be like,
you know,
there'll be like Watson.
They would be like one of the great
scientists of all times.
Someone has invented something.
They would be like,
I mean you,
you could go back in time and think
about all the big inventors,
the teslas and all the different people.
Someone who can invent something that
cures the black plague of the 20th
century,
which is what AIDS was.
Still a lot of people,
someone came along and cured that,
God damn,
they'd be big.
They'd be giant.
I don't think you can keep that shit
quiet because I'm going to lose it.
Make sense?
Now May,
I guess I'm agreeing with the conspiracy
theorists.
Oh,
I've heard on this podcast,
you can't totally listen to them.
Not because their ideas are invalid,
but because a lot of times they don't
absolutely know and people jumped to
conclusions,
so it's not,
the conspiracies don't exist because
they definitely exist.
We all know that.
Some people can spire to do certain
things.
It happens all the time,
but it's whether or not the conspiracies
that we just get really attached to,
whether or not they're,
they're real and oftentimes they're just
not.
You know,
I still believe in time travel time
travel is totally possible.
I just don't think it's happened yet.
Everyone was like,
dude,
I think everything's possible,
man.
I think we're going to come to some
weird point in time,
whether it's like I said a thousand
years from now,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's going to be a weird point in time
where we could do anything we want.
Jamie put pull up that fucking video
that you showed me yesterday.
Good googly movement.
You ready to get your mind ready?
But he seen us Nvidia Shit.
[inaudible] get on Jamie.
Am I done three hours.
You gotta you gotta see this right?
I'll hold it to Wa.
You gotta pee.
I gotta pee,
but I can keep talking.
Why don't you it and Brian and I will
have a little chit chat while you're
gone and then we'll come back in and joy
this joy.
No,
we're going to be good.
It's Roy Choi Shit.
Can you believe that Brian?
What the Fuck Bert Kreischer remember
that part of you
Indiana Jones where she's riding an
elephant and then she sprays Cologne on
the elephant and it cause the elephants
smelled.
No,
I hated that part.
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh my God,
it's so ridiculous.
I broke this lighter while I was sitting
here and I didn't know why I was doing
it while I was doing it.
I just kept pushing on little pieces of
lighter and pieces are breaking off.
I was like,
get the fuck is wrong with you.
They got like lighter fluid all over.
You're going to light it a joint.
Yeah,
I didn't,
but I'm like,
why?
What is it about pot that makes you uh,
one thing at a time is just not
interesting enough.
He got to thinking about time travel and
chipotle lay and how do I break this
lighter with two fingers?
Can I you just use two fingers and break
the slider?
I won't push with the third finger at
all.
He says time travel is possible.
He thinks it's just not technologically
here yet.
He says he needs about 250,000
to make a scale
model of his machine.
But if you could get funding like the
hard drum collider,
like 10 billion,
then they could probably do it.
This is Ma Mallet says that's what he
said.
Jesus Christ.
I would say that too though.
Yeah,
he give me funding like the fucking
larger green cartoons,
the life.
It's like shark tank and try that on.
Check this out.
Cause this is the Nvidia tilt brush,
is that what's called Jamie?
It's on the HTC vive.
Uh,
Google bought this APP and they're
pushing it out as this thing just became
a made for preorder this week.
It's like a three d room you're in and
a,
you have like a wand and a pallet kind
of on wandon right hand pallet on your
left hand.
And with some tools you could kind of
pick from explain what you're seeing
right now.
But uh,
yeah,
so this guy was painting was all sorts
of different colors.
There's hyper color,
there's a different oil pinning things,
but you painting in three d it looks
like you're painting on a two d plane
and immediately it becomes available to
your eyes that you're not painting.
And just today,
like you've been used to your whole
life,
you're actually in a speedy,
cool playing live sculpting.
You know what I want to see though,
I want to see you be able to do that in
paint.
And then be able to print it out on your
printer.
You can't unit but you can share it.
Yeah.
You,
well you can't now,
but one day,
three d printer would be able to
recreate the same way people can pour
molten silver into an ant colony and
pull out a fucking ant thing.
You've gotta be able to take this thing,
print that too.
He's growing.
He's,
he's drawing a monster's inc type
monster and then getting to touch it.
Well,
not only that,
he's making flames come out of these
things.
Oh,
this is bad ass.
I look at that.
Beautiful.
I can't wait to draw Jodi with big boobs
and 3-d dude.
Find out when it's available and we will
purchase out that you can buy it now.
It won't ship until like a couple of
more weeks until they fucking do it,
Brian.
And we get this.
Do you ever,
do you ever do one of those uh,
uh,
cast with this?
Yes.
No.
What was link people up to this?
Jamie.
What's the,
what's going to so much fun?
You can get video outputs,
dragon to back it up,
back it up.
Just a second dude,
Look at that.
That's insane.
There's some really cool art being made
with this.
The guy that showed this to me,
Chadwick at circle vr cities working
with,
uh,
I maybe I shouldn't even say,
but some cool visual artists that are
making some really,
really awesome things.
Wow.
There's that.
And you get to almost interact with it.
You can,
you can explore this space.
So like,
uh,
this,
this is actual actual program records,
all the movements and motions that
you're making.
You can upload them and share them and
download them on your own.
And then watch,
like I could watch Brian Paint,
Joey Diaz or however you want to do.
You were talking right now and most of
the people are just listening to this.
So if you want to see the video,
the video's entitled,
uh,
Nvidia powers tilt brush art contest at
htc vine at Pax 2015 and it's amazing.
I mean,
it's really,
it's one of the most amazing things I've
ever seen.
When you look at like the future,
like you look at technology
in the future and you think like,
what,
what does entertainment going to be like
when you see something like this?
I mean,
you're going to have like full on dmt
trips with a headset.
Yeah,
100%.
You're not even going to have to do a
drug.
And you know,
that's something McKenna predicted.
Terence Mckenna predicted that one day
through virtual reality.
They would figure out a way to recreate
the DMT dimension and you'd be able to
go there without actually being fucked
up without actually being intoxicated on
dmt.
You'd be able to go there.
I think DMT is the existence of time
trouble.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's something weird,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
Kill that.
It's talking about that a lot.
Why I reached out to that.
Have you done?
No,
I reached out to dunk and talk to him
about it.
You want to do it?
Uh,
I told him I did and he said he thought
it was a bad idea.
Why?
It's like I say that knows pretty well,
you know,
I don't have that Brent.
Maybe I don't have the brain.
I want to babysit you,
man.
You sure?
Now,
right up there,
I've done every drug there is,
but I've never done dmt and I don't know
if my,
my biggest fear right now is not,
it's not the trip.
It's not the con,
it's the fact that I have two children
and they rely on my brain to make them
money.
So for me to fuck with my brain for me
is not the greatest thing because I got
a pretty fragile brain.
You know,
we've all heard of this podcast.
I fucking drink a bottle of wine on a
treadmill.
Like I'm not the guy that maybe belongs
rolling the dice and going,
let's see what happens.
What are you worried that would happen
but don't come back.
You don't come back.
That's it.
Come like the dude from pink floyd and
just lose your marbles or diamond.
Yeah,
and I'll probably Williams whatever his
name is.
[inaudible]
since he got high on acid,
he was in Vietnam.
I was in the shit.
Shit man.
Ryan,
you weren't even in that country.
You were in Iraq was the only reason.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It was.
The only reason I won't do it is a,
it's just a pure,
I don't come back.
Well,
that's a legitimate fear.
That's it.
I love my kids.
I want them to have a great life and I
committed to that when I had them and
that's my fear.
Do I respect you massively for allowing
a differentiation in,
in family and and,
and,
and the extra treasure psychosis or
whatever the,
whatever the thing is,
psychedelic say.
That's it.
Can I tell you what I all,
I could think that whole time.
Why don't you guys have,
could you,
could you guys have an a,
a vr camera,
a virtual reality camera on the side so
people could throw on goggles,
smoke a joint,
watching show like they were sitting in
the room.
That's definitely going to happen.
I think that's bad.
I think it's going to happen.
I'm telling you.
No Way.
We'll be able to stop it.
Sorry.
It's already happening to us.
Right?
What about how many years away,
Jamie?
Less than a year.
Let's do it.
I'll make it happen tomorrow.
Crazy.
You don't get an eagle,
the eagle on us and there's no reason
already.
People that have like live shows like I
like it like a live podcasts video where
if feels like you're sitting in the
studio and he just can walk and look
around and do whatever you're doing.
That's the show.
I know the brilliance of it.
I loved what I love about it and when I
listen,
I feel like I'm in the room when I'll
watch it,
I still feel like I'm in the room.
But man,
I would be cool to be able to be on the
road and throwing some glasses and just
feel like I'm sitting there.
It's gonna happen.
It's 100% going to happen.
There's no way around it.
Did you guys watch the Oscars and see
like all the Samsung?
I like things where they now have like
the glasses where you just snap your
phone in a day.
They now advertise.
Oh,
virtual reality goggles.
We just take it like,
well,
you're no five unbox therapy.
Brought those in.
Yeah,
and I put that on,
man.
Did you put it on?
Did you try it out?
But now they're actually advertising it
on tv to the masses,
like the moms and the dads on the
corner.
And the one that Samsung has is,
is cool but there's one that has a
higher resolution,
like not just like the cell phone one is
like real simple because you just use
your existing cell phone,
you slide it into this sort of bracket
you put on the headphones.
But they have some that are attached to
computers,
you know,
they're the really intensive programming
as far as like their ability to,
uh,
to computate like the big thing about
visuals and about artificial reality and
about virtual reality.
The big thing is computational power.
It's to be able to create a seamless
reality all the time.
Like it's one of the things that you
would always see when you would play
video games.
It's like a little bit of lag.
Like if your computer was struggling
because your um,
you know,
your video card couldn't keep up with
the,
the resolution of the,
of the screen and the frames per second
that you had it set up down.
Well the,
you the resolution is a big one cause it
it would establish with the frames per
second where,
because like most video cards like in
when I used to make pcs I used to buy
like pcs.
I just buy the shell and buy a
motherboard and hard drives and shit.
And uh,
my friend Andrew would,
he would always help me out.
Here's my security net in case things
went bad cause I was like okay what the
fuck is next?
And I would get on the phone with him
from Oklahoma and he would talk me
through it.
But it's only making toast.
Yeah.
But creating a pc that's like,
one of the big things is like if you
want to game on it,
the old video cards,
a lot of them you'd have to connect to
video cards together and form an Sli
connection that allowed you to have like
double the processing power in order for
you to play at a high resolution.
Otherwise you'd have turned the
resolution.
And I was way low so that it looked like
shit.
Like some guys would even take away all
the,
um,
the textures.
So like say you would be playing quake,
so you'd be going down a dark dungeon.
It would look cool as fuck and you would
see good crazy lighting and the graphics
are amazing.
But to the hardcore competitive gamers,
that shit was just distracting.
So what they would do is they would take
all the textures out and they would turn
the entire space that you were playing
in and to this white canvas with you.
Like you are a bright red and they can
even change what your character
represented on their screen.
So like you would say like,
I'm going to be like this little chick
character because the chick character is
really difficult to hit cause she's so
small.
It's hard to pinpoint even though they
all have the same sort of box that you
could shoot them in.
But it was to be harder to pinpoint.
And other people would say,
well what I want is everybody I play to
be the giant square robot.
So they're an easy target.
So you see this like this,
this is what quake looks like.
This is quake three.
What it looks like when they turn off
all the textures.
There's probably better ones out there,
Jim.
And we can see like a death match.
We'll see.
There's no texture.
So you don't see any texture on the
ground.
You don't see any graphics.
Everything's sort of muted.
Is this theoretically what the premise
of the matrix was where he just saw
number
verse?
No,
no,
no.
But this is,
is just,
she just,
it's a last,
it's kind of cheating a lot of people's
eyes.
It makes you green also.
Like,
oh there's the bright green guy.
Yeah,
you can change,
you can change what their character is.
So like say you don't have the,
you don't have the right,
like say if you decide that you were a
girl in the game.
And a lot of guys,
like I said,
played as a girl because it was small.
You,
you don't get to decide how other people
see you.
Other people can see you as a giant
circle.
Like instead of even seeing you as a
person or a seeing is as a moving thing,
they could see you as a circle that
doesn't change and you just become a
target.
So it's way easier to hit you that it is
for you to hit.
It was way,
way easier for them to hit you,
then it's for you to hit them because
you've become a giant target.
Whereas you're playing the game the way
it's intended and they're just,
uh,
you know,
an octopus with a machine gun or
whatever the fuck their characters.
So you can kind of manipulate things and
change in the settings.
And some people like it because it makes
it real simple.
You know,
like it's,
it's such a fast paced game anyway.
They don't want to be there.
They're not there for all that bullshit.
They're not there for textures and the
way it looks,
they're just that kick ass and spray
people,
rail gun people in the middle of the
air.
It would bounce off these bouncy pad.
You can't talk.
You can't talk to me about,
uh,
about,
video games without thinking about the
way dunk and looked at him when he was
addicted to them.
Oh yeah.
I think about that so much.
Cause you know,
it's like when he was like,
is it different kind of video game too.
He plays a video game that you become
like a part of the game.
He's into those like massive multiplayer
games,
you know.
Hey,
I remember driving through the training
through the hills.
They can,
oh,
that's the mountains of till door or
whatever.
Ah,
uh,
no,
but I used to be addicted to,
this sounds silly,
really silly,
but to Tony Hawk's,
uh,
ice skater,
it was so good.
You were addicted to a skating game.
I was addicted to video games.
It's just the idea of getting into the
same format.
It's just like drinking or drugs.
I'm sure the same rituals,
you know,
and then all of a sudden the same
payoff.
But just imagine once this shit,
this,
this technology does virtual reality
technology we were just looking at,
imagine if that becomes
the new video game,
then things are going to be so bizarre
because all all they're going to have to
do is figure out some sort of a body
suit that,
that you were where the,
the actions of your environment
correspond how the body suit feels like.
Like you could sit there with this
virtual reality thing on and stand there
and when things grab at you,
it'll feel like something's actually
grabbing you.
Like it's gonna get weirder and weirder
and then eventually they going to go,
listen man,
we can give you what we're giving you
right now,
but it's not as good as we can do.
And what we can do is we can cut your
brain open and we could put these
electrodes in there and I can guarantee
you,
you are going to be a super person.
You're going to be one of the avengers.
You're going to live in the moon.
You're going to get your dick sucked.
Anytime you snap your finger twice,
you're going to have a a Harem of golden
girls from planet pussy that are here to
suck your Dick 24 hours a day just
waiting and like a corral like
immigrants trying to fucking come off of
a raft and escaped to freedom.
That's what's going to be like every day
of your life.
All you gotta do is cut your head open,
but it takes some wires in there.
What will happen is the same thing as my
wife and your wife grown chickens and
grown eggs.
They'll all the sudden,
40 years from now,
they'll be like,
you know what?
I'm going to have a child.
Like it's the same thing,
man.
Your wife does it.
My wife does it.
They grow,
they have chickens and they grow eggs
and they fucking find some sort of
pleasure in like almost dislike 20 year
jump at 50 or jump back,
but like having an animal and I know you
love those eggs.
I know I fucking love those eggs.
When I cracked those eggs open and I go,
I met.
I never eat.
I never eat scrambled eggs my life until
I got chickens.
Now I'm like fucking scrambled eggs.
You get away with eating.
No scrambled eggs over easy.
I don't fuck with scrambled eggs,
but man,
now that I know they're in my backyard,
a little wet scrambled egg with some
cheese on it.
That's the best God damn thing in the
world because they're my eggs,
but so the same thing will happen is
that progression will give just like
tomatoes and cucumbers and Kale,
all that shit.
We get a store back in the day.
They had to grow it.
They never fucked with it.
Same thing will happen is one day
someone would be like,
man,
it's going to sound crazy.
I'm thinking about getting a hand job
and someone would be like,
what?
From like a person?
They're like,
yeah,
I'm going to disconnect.
I'm going to get one hand job.
I want to see what it feels like.
I've heard about it so tired that people
hooked up to the Matrix.
You wouldn't be able to jerk you off
correctly.
And it was like really tired,
atrophied hands because they haven't
moved in months.
He didn't disconnect
good though because they don't have an
energy and then after they're done they
have to rest for days.
They're exhausted.
Arm swells up with inflammation is your
tore all the ligaments and their arm
cause they're just not used to moving it
and they jerked you off.
But look at you like hunting,
hunting with the airfoil hands with the
eggs.
I mean there's,
there's a also,
because we are,
we are a part of the generation that
came before us.
They gave birth to us,
you know the people for them gave birth
to them and all you have to do is go
back three or four times and you live on
savages.
Okay.
That's not that far away.
Not that far away.
You can do that like five or six times.
You get to the point where there's no
electricity.
He get to the point where people are
burning wood and coal and shit to stay
alive.
Like he's not that far.
Where you do that.
You don't do that like 10 or 11 times.
Do you get to like barbarian type
people,
but then you got to keep people going,
let's go camping.
But this is what I'm saying is like when
we're looking at the future and we're
saying this is a real slippery slope,
like there's always gonna be people that
want eggs.
There's going to be,
it didn't,
it was there.
I don't want you to cut into their brain
and create the perfect reality.
They're going to be happy with their
imperfect,
but yet realistic reality.
I know this is real.
I don't,
I,
I'm not going to take that magic leap
into you drilling a hole in my head and
sticking in some sort of a Usb port and
plug me into the Matrix.
I'm not ready.
So they decided to go out,
but their kids might not do that,
man.
You know,
it might,
it might be one of those generational
things where it takes just a few
generations of people to go,
why are you camping?
Why you camping?
Do you want to live with dragons?
Do you want to fly to the moon on your
Dick?
Can you want to shoot your Dick like a
fucking pogo stick and the launch
yourself into the fucking asteroid belt?
Well,
you can do it dude.
Okay.
And it'll feel like you're really doing
it.
You don't have to fucking camping.
Camping.
Oh my God.
You see a bird?
Did you see a bird for real?
Did you wash your asshole and stream
your shifts?
Standing Up Shane road a dragon into a
black hole.
You fucking pussy.
Take the operation,
let them stick the USB port in your
brain and let's do this then the next
generation.
So I'm not saying it's a good idea,
I'm just saying it's going to happen.
I just want all I want.
Jamie is vr right there so I could throw
on the goggles right now on the road and
just be like,
you'd never get anything done.
I just know it's just every now and
then,
just the same way I watch a podcast,
but dote on and be in the room.
That would be bad ass.
That would be bad ass like just for
right now.
Those fixes in life.
Just throw on the goggles and be in the
room.
It'd be really fun.
It'd be so connected to that technology.
You'd want it all the time.
Could,
it'd be so much more spectacular than
regular life.
You'd want it all the time.
It'd be a real problem,
you think?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because if you lived your life without
it and then all of a sudden it was an
option,
it'd be so you'd be like,
why would I do those other things like
I'm really confused.
There's certain options that would be
before people would probably a hundred
people,
a lot,
a lot of hundred percent.
A lot of people would,
a lot of people would not be able to
handle it.
It's almost like we're not born with the
discipline or the even the concept of
those kinds of parameters,
like I think that's what's going on with
these massive multiplayer games.
Guys like Dunkin and you remember rob,
the dude from the comedy store we've
talked about often who is addicted to
everquest?
Same.
Same kind of stuff.
Do you just get you,
you get influenced by something that
you're not really,
you don't
have an immune system for it.
He don't have like an intellectual
immune system to say,
okay,
this is not real.
So we have to decide what we're doing
here.
Are we going to live in the shittiest
fucking neighborhood possible and rent
the worst fucking apartment possible as
long as it's got an internet connection
and just plug in and be there all day?
Or are we going to try to live a
comfortable existence on earth
and material earth where you can afford
to pay your bills?
You don't freak out and occasionally use
this thing.
How do we do this?
How do you manage this?
Because if it's so much better than real
life,
if you put it on and all of a sudden
you're an avatar and it feels like
Avatar and you're having a fucking great
time and you're jumping through the
trees and landing in these hammocks and
shit,
and you're all fucking flying dragons
around and going to war and getting
hooked up to that tree there guy,
that's gonna be real,
they're going to have that where it's
going to be something that they've
invented it.
They can send your mind and it won't
even be artificial.
That's what it's not going to be like
some like previously created narrative
where it's got a beginning and an end
like dragon's layer.
Remember that video game where you'd
fucking turn the handle to the left?
It's into the right
cliff.
Now,
now talking about that.
I'm talking about that computations are
gonna reach a point where it's so
fucking powerful.
They're going to be able to create a
real world where you're going to feel
pebbles into your feet.
You're going gonna feel sand.
We're going to be thirsty.
Are you going to,
your Dick's going to get hard.
You're going to feel like you're really
there,
it's going to be indistinguishable.
And it's,
it's a matter of time.
It's not if it's when it's 100%,
when,
when you see that this is Morse code,
this is banging on coconuts.
That's a smoke signal.
That's what that is.
This is,
it's common,
man.
It's going to save marriages too,
because you can be able to like put
these little yellow or green dots on
your wife and then go like,
download any girl you want and be like,
oh,
I'm fucking Roseanne Barr.
Right?
Because we get so mad at my wife's never
greenlight.
And that stopped with the downloads.
Can we do it without the dots tonight?
Sorry.
Can we do it without the dots?
I live a pretty amazing life.
I love my life.
I think there were a lot of,
a lot to be a lot of people that trade
with me,
but every now and then I'd like to throw
in some goggles and a bed in a hotel
room and just hang out in the room and
listening to guys podcast.
I'm,
that's all I'm saying.
That's,
I'm talking,
uh,
like you bringing it all back.
Yeah,
like that's the first thing I think is
those things are here.
We can get them,
Samsung's got them plug one in.
Let me get those things,
those things.
That's Nvidia.
That's not the Samsung one is the one
with the cell phone and there's pretty
good Jason's we're talking about,
we've talked about it early on.
Video Shit is complete next level,
next back to the next level on the next,
next,
next level.
And when that,
when that becomes something that I think
what we're going to do,
and I think we should probably talk
about this once we're done here,
I think the best way to do it is to find
out when they're available and then like
set up some sort of a new studio.
Like a new room in here.
I got you covered.
You know like we have that other room.
We could do something back in there.
Like a room for it.
It's based off of a room.
Yeah.
I got you.
I got you covered.
Okay.
I've,
I've been approached by a bit of traffic
channel.
It just doesn't work with us.
So I'll set my guy up with you guys.
I'll just set them up with Jamie.
But uh,
it doesn't work for us.
So will you be on the first podcast?
We do from there hundred percent naked
naked.
I didn't ask for that.
I'll fuck your mouth.
Racist.
A Gong is racist.
Fucking inman.
I think that,
I mean,
as a fan of pot,
you know,
you've got to always come realize I come
at this,
all of this and you know this,
but I'm the first time I met you and I
was like,
dude,
I got to see the dog,
the deprivation tank,
the pool table.
I'm a fan always of comedy of podcasting
and I can tell you what the consumer
wants because this is what I,
how,
this is how I use podcasts and the way
people use it that listened to it.
And then when I'm on the road bike,
I like to,
I like to get lost.
I lay in bed and listen to it in the
phone and I just kind of like fall
asleep and disappear into it.
That is the next level of podcasting I
believe because man,
I'm telling you,
I got a loan out on the road.
It would be so much easier for me to
like pour a glass of wine,
throw on some goggles,
and they'd just be with you guys and
just be like going to happen.
It's,
it's,
and it's unavoidable.
I think the same way when you're sitting
in your man cave and you watch a
Netflix,
what are you doing?
I mean you're,
you're watching narcos.
Narcos.
Thank you.
Eddie Bravo.
Why'd you decide when to watch it?
Right?
So you just sit down,
you press play and it's a,
it's entertaining you,
you know,
and it plays right in front of you.
Imagine if you could just say magically,
just if I could just go,
you know what honey?
I'm going to go back to the room and
hang out with Brian and Joe and Jamie
and I just throw on some goggles and
then hit play and all of a sudden I'm in
the room.
We're all in this room.
Just feels like it feels like this.
Yeah.
And you're just chilling.
Yeah,
that's the name.
I mean,
and they can be a guy you let in every
week that actually can sit in.
He have someone pull up a chair and sit
in the virtual world with Dato.
Yeah.
To like prescreen them.
I make sure I'm not out of their fucking
mind.
Are you jacking off,
hey,
is what I'm seeing?
Really what you're doing.
Guess how could you be jacking off the
entire time esther Ku style.
But meanwhile you're,
you're the dude with the pocket
handkerchief and the tie clip.
This is the right room to make that
happen.
And I'm being dead serious when I say
this.
Like,
and like I said,
we've been approached for travel
channel.
People have come to us and go,
hey,
could you do vr?
It just doesn't work for a network TV
show.
I'll send whatever p context.
I have this way to Jamie.
And because as a fan,
that is what I'd like to watch.
I'd like to be here.
I'd like to sit right there.
I really want to sit right here,
but it's going to happen.
It's just what we're,
we're,
we're experiencing right now is the
beginning of a new revolution in
entertainment where movies are going to
play out like that.
I think there's also going to be movies
with not just one,
but multiple different
possibilities like at every turn.
Really.
Yeah.
I think there's going to be interactive
movies.
I think what they're gonna do is they're
going to figure out a way to engineer
virtual reality into an integrated,
integrated environment where the virtual
reality is interactive and there's a
bunch of different potentials.
So like instead of like,
say if you,
uh,
if there's a movie,
you know,
um,
American Werewolf in London,
it's got a really specific beginning,
a really specific moment where it
becomes a werewolf specific moment
where,
uh,
his girlfriend realizes he's aware of
wolf and then he gets killed.
There's all these specific moments that
what if instead of all those specific
moments,
it's completely interactive.
Like you're actually there in London and
you are this American guy and your
friend is put my fucking mind.
Yeah,
you're friendly.
and you can,
you can not only you in London,
but you're in the fucking,
you're in the bogs.
You're walking around in Scotland,
you're,
you're going to go to the fucking pub
where the slaughtered lamb.
Remember they had the head on the wall.
All that stuff's going to be possible.
You're going to feel the rain.
You're going to feel the moisture.
They get to do a tap into your fucking
dope man.
They're going to be able to do something
to your brain that makes you think
you're really experiencing it.
You just proved me wrong and all the
stuff,
they were like,
it's perfect for travel.
And I was like,
I don't get it.
I'm looking at it and then you're like,
I'm like,
I could be in London,
like throwing goggles a be fucking
walking through Austria.
It's going to happen.
That's the fucking future mining.
It might not happen.
Why?
We're alive.
I think it's going to,
I think it's just going to be just like
when,
when you go to Disneyland or anything
where it's like,
Hey,
I'm wa on the needs for speed.
Right.
And they're like,
Joe,
come here.
I need your help.
But to just going to be way more intense
than a horse ride at Disneyland is a
better example.
Well cause they have like 68 different
endings or different stories that play
out.
Have you been on those rides where they
are like,
I only know that universal in Orlando
has them,
but it's like the spiderman ride,
the whole crowd where it's a screen and
it's a,
it's a cart that technically doesn't
move technically,
but the screen shoots fire at you in
suits Smith.
Yeah.
And you feel like you're free falling 90
feet.
Yeah.
Have you been in the news?
I've been on those.
I haven't been on that one a bit.
Um,
but I've been on other ones like that.
Those are awesome.
Those are the ones that I believe when
we can't cover them on birth to conquer,
but all those rods because it's
impossible.
So I was teen possible.
It's TV.
It's not,
there's no,
it's not the smell.
You're like,
you know,
like when you're on the sentence,
right.
He smells,
it's just wild.
It's just,
it's literally like watching like,
like,
oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
You can't get like a little bit of video
of it.
I don't know.
I'm going to try.
Barb was shooting an episode.
I think people would want to see the
little bit of video even till they go,
Huh,
I don't even see anything.
And then you could explain.
Yeah,
nothing is actually happening.
It's amazing.
It's uh,
it's like the raiders of the lost ark or
writers a little bit like that,
but a little more driven thing.
The raiders of the lost Ark is moving,
goes fucking rods blow me away every
time when you go,
when it's just a screen.
I am like a child,
like,
like Ha,
like literally grabbing pete.
What I mean,
that's,
I guess that's the premise of the show
also.
But man,
I am falling fucking apart.
They're going to be able to have things
like that times a million.
Do I think the next,
the next generation rollercoasters I was
talking to events and about this is
because you know,
Doug's a big roller coaster fan.
What does best is a really big roller
coaster fan.
Like the massive dude.
Massive.
Does he have like pins?
Uh,
no,
but he flies.
He flies himself out for the opening.
Abroad's like Doug Benson.
I can't talk to him.
He loves rollercoasters.
What was the last time you were on a
rollercoaster?
They're fucking amazing.
They really are fucking amazing.
There's certain things that people that
look,
draw a line in the sand or you're fan of
cricket.
Cricket's fucking amazing.
It lasts for four days.
How great would that be if I wasn't
really?
Yeah.
Last one.
How great would it be if you had like an
ongoing communal event?
Like what's the score today?
Doesn't really,
four days.
40 days straight.
2020 cricket last for a day.
Regular cricket usually lasts for like
four days.
Dang.
Don't you dare get Google list.
Jamie,
what a weird game.
It's so funny how baseballs weird too,
but it's normal.
Yeah.
Cause we're used to that weird.
You know other,
other people like what the fuck is,
but baseball so boring like in
comparison to a lot of other sports like
comparison to soccer.
They can understand why soccer never
took hold.
We were like,
Eh,
not buying it.
So whoever took cold,
the whole world loves it.
The whole world there is a soccer never
took hold was advertising.
Um,
no because America,
no,
it's advertising.
That's because America,
no,
soccer was very popular in the 70s never
was popular.
Oh,
tony was bro.
That's like big foot.
That's like some shit native Americans
talk about around a campfire flashing.
Your lights went to the other car when
there is no headlights on and you're
going to get shy as a gang initiation.
You didn't hear about that one.
No.
Sour cream talking about,
I think I saw a movie with Ethan Hawke
about the terrible Richard Gere.
That's true time.
Sigora your Dick.
Oh,
oh.
Necessary.
Have we broken over the three hour
point?
Oh,
for sure.
Okay.
I'm just wondering because I keep
feeling like I should wrap it up into
it.
You want to wrap it?
We wrapping it.
Let's wrap it.
Let's have a fake wrap.
We fake wrapped it.
I can figure out if it not wrapping it
ourselves.
Another conversation just got perfect.
Um,
it's good.
It's in a good place.
I'm very happy.
I've gotten over the stupor of about 40
minutes ago where I was so high shit and
I've been talking to anybody that I hit.
I hit a moment where I was like,
Whoa,
wait.
My idea was good.
It's just,
I couldn't remember what it was halfway
into it.
The idea of being like pick a regular
job and a,
if like eight out of 10 people that came
there wanting to fuck you,
but it probably,
if a girl was Washington guys balls and
Asshole,
I'll probably be more than eight out of
10.
I'm probably really conservative.
But this girl that was she,
I mean she knew that was a part of her
job.
She made more money.
It's a different gig.
I saw you hit that joint more than I've
ever seen.
You had a joint.
It's pretty strong.
Pretty
strong stuff.
We were deep.
Who went in the hole deep in the rabbit?
Oh No.
Soliciting crusher.
A who gives a fuck?
He's catching up there.
He's got to have a lean,
is trying to kill his neighbor's dogs.
Do you know about that?
Havoline is killed the fucking dog down
the street from him.
How about lit with the hub?
Lena havoline is a weird,
it looks like a pig,
but it's actually like a cousin of a
pig.
I think it was called a peccary.
I think that's the,
the technical name for what kind of an
animal it is.
But it's this weird freaky looking thing
that lives in the American southwest and
those motherfuckers were,
will kill dogs.
Uh,
they,
uh,
they killed a dog and Stan hope,
but I understand what they do is they
flank them,
they get on the side of them and they
just fuck it all run at him and tear him
apart.
So if they have,
you know,
you let some domesticated really soft
dog loose and you,
uh,
leave him out there in,
the plains where,
where do they live?
The desert desert desert.
You leave them out there in the desert
to play.
These mother fuckers literally might
jump on him.
And eat him.
Like,
look,
get those teeth.
Those are aggressive.
They don't really go after people.
Here's a,
here's a really interesting thing about
Havalinas there a,
an animal that responds in an insane way
to what's called a Predator call.
And a Predator call is look at the
fucking teeth on that thing.
That's how the biggest Havalina,
they're not that big,
but they're fucking for Roche.
These are ferocious animals.
There's so powerful.
Um,
so they take this sound,
a Predator call is like a sound of an
animal.
It's dying.
So they have this thing.
It's like something in agony and pain.
These motherfuckers come running like
you've never seen anything before.
Like the way my friend Remy Warren
described it,
he said,
havoline has come to a Predator call the
way you wish all animals came to a
Predator call.
Like when you call them,
they come running at you full blast
running cause Wayne to Jack.
Whatever's making that noise.
Like it's a race between them and all
the other monsters behind them that are
chasing to try to find this rabbit.
It's screaming,
they're probably broke its leg or
something.
Oh Dude,
holy.
When you see them run,
they just running towards that sound
like full clip and not cautious at all.
They just trying to get it in as quick
as they can.
Who should?
The wild is so fucking scary,
dude.
Wild animals are solo.
Scary.
The wild of being a fucking peccary
running around and dug stan hopes
neighborhood trying to get by in the
desert.
Seven miles away from Mexico.
Have you seen man on a buffalo?
I've met this guy.
He rides a buffalo around like it's a
horse and then he gets attacked by a
cougar and say as a baby and all this
stuff.
It's like a documentary from the 70s
that's really good.
And I highly recommend episodes of man
and the Buffalo.
No,
no.
It's anything after that.
That
is the perfect sentence.
Dropped a fucking champ.
Lower fins,
cougars and whatnot.
Yeah.
A guy on a buffalo episode to tell you
something.
I'm seeing this greatest video on the
roses and saying,
how does he get the Buffalo?
Listen,
I don't know,
but those are the most unpredictable
animals baby in the middle of nowhere we
wrote,
we drove.
We drove buffalo across Texas and it's
like one of the most unpredictable
animals just wants to be the worst show
ever.
And then if you listen to the song
unfortunate look,
the baby's about to charter schools in
the water and has to rescue the baby.
I think this is a joke Bryan.
No,
no,
no.
This is a real movie and the Seventies
Watch,
um,
cause watched it.
The next thing I fucking cougar just
attacks on.
Hang on Jamie.
Back it up.
Two shotguns,
Joe.
Listen lyrics.
I think this might be a joke now that
song it guy.
This guy took a real movie and just,
yeah,
the song's good.
Sounds fake.
Let's,
let's go to the Cougar Park.
Um,
do you remember Grizzly Adams?
Oh fuck yeah.
That guy just died,
right?
Right here.
Yeah.
The guys crawling look into killed his
deer and then a wolf attacks the buffalo
and the buffalo likes like get Outta
here,
man.
Shit,
this cougar really is hanging on this
guy.
How the fuck did they train that cat
punching the cat and he's my God.
It's fun.
I picked that scripting gone wrong.
And how do you,
do you think so?
Of course you're,
I've worked with [inaudible].
Oh Shit.
A Wolf came after that.
Buffalo and God,
yeah.
Don't,
yeah,
I worked with lions and uh,
wait,
what?
Yeah.
Worked with,
no,
I worked with lions.
Bears and elephants.
Yeah,
of course.
One of the Elian fucks with you.
It's,
it's not that aggressive.
It's like,
it's like Paul Paul.
So what that was doing was a fucked up
like a fuck up,
but it looks like the trainer that was
probably the trainer they shot that
cause it looks like a train or knowing
how to handle an animal like that.
Like when,
when I fought a bear,
I saw the,
I reached out,
I found the video of it.
Come kill.
Don't kill this movie for me,
man.
No,
that's why I had the marshmallow church.
I've told you a story a million times.
No,
I'm not movie kill the Buffalo Guy
Movie.
Oh yeah.
I'm pretty fucked up.
But like when you fight a bear or are
you fighting a lion,
it really is uninteresting.
Yeah.
It's a lot of like interesting.
It's,
it's scary for you.
And doing it.
But when you watch it on video,
it's a lot like,
it's a lot more dramatic for you in the
moment than it looks because they're
very fucking team.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
so if you want,
I told her on Ari's,
this is not happening story.
I fought a bear but it's,
it's,
yeah,
but it's,
it's literally like you feel like you're
getting lifted off the ground and shaken
by your head,
but they're just moving you around a
little bit.
But they're so fucking powerful that
literally to watch that.
I mean just in my own experience and I
fought a lot of animals.
I,
I look at that and I just go,
how do you not have this in your act?
Like he fought a lot of animals cause
man,
I'm trying to talk to him about my kids.
I go to this chunk of my kids are going
to get rid of this,
got rid of them,
my wife,
Shit.
And then I'm fucking April 1st at the
Irvine Improv.
Ladies and gentlemen,
come see one of the funniest man on the
planet earth.
Bert Kreischer film has show time
special for tickets.
Go Do Bert Bert,
bert.com
please subscribe to the Bert Kreischer
podcast.
Please also subscribe to the what red
band.
Do podcasts new and improved.
No new.
It's a great podcast.
It's improved from the first one to the,
the next one to the next one.
That next more improved.
Just as is this one.
We're all a work in progress.
You fuck.
Stop being so critical.
We'll see you soon.
Ladies and gentlemen and promotion.
Yeah.
Desk Squad,
Austin and Houston.
Next and next week.
March 11th,
Houston 12th 13th and talented George
Perez.
And then want to see him do stand up.
The funny guy.
Good dude to Bert Kreischer and he lasts
words.
Uh,
call in sick to work show March 17th
grand rapids distillery.
Wise guys in Utah right before my
special April 1st in Irvine.
Joe,
I love you.
I love you and your brother is always a
great pleasure.
All right folks.
See You guys in Vegas tomorrow night.
Joey Diaz,
Tony Hinchcliffe and me will be at the
cop theater.
Can't wait for that.
Then the UFC is the next night.
Who's going to win?
Joe,
who's phone?
Yeah.